Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridloff und ich begrüße alle zur 124.
Ausgabe von UKW.
Und nachdem wir hier in der letzten Sendung mal so einen kleinen,
zumindest vorübergehenden Schlussstrich unter die Brexit-Saga gemacht haben
mit John, wird es kaum zu eurer Überraschung heute wieder um die Ukraine gehen
und deswegen sage ich Hallo zu Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Denn es ist ja wieder eine Menge passiert. Wir haben heute den 16. August 2024.
Das bedeutet, dass wir wieder knapp zwei Monate ausgesessen haben.
Und es war halt wieder so eine Phase, wo vieles immer so wieder dasselbe in grün war.
Es ging wieder nichts voran.
Bis denn dann auf einmal vor einer Woche alles auf einmal komplett anders war.
Wir sprechen natürlich heute ausführlich über die Invasion der Ukrainer auf
russisches Staatsgebiet in der Region Kursk und auch in der Region Belgorod.
Und werden aber jetzt vorher auch überhaupt erst nochmal, wie immer,
einen Überblick liefern über die militärische Lage insgesamt.
Aber dann vor allem uns mit dieser neuen Situation beschäftigen,
was dort tatsächlich bisher passiert zu sein scheint und was das auch für politische
Implikationen hat, sowohl für die Ukraine als auch für Russland als auch weltweit.
Da ist auf jeden Fall jetzt eine Menge in Bewegung gekommen.
Ja, und dann reden wir noch ein bisschen über Militärtechnik,
geben vielleicht ein kurzes Update zu der Situation rund um diese Nord Stream
Anschläge, die ja schon einige Zeit zurückliegen, aber wo es jetzt neue Bewegungen gibt.
Ja, und dann schauen wir nochmal vielleicht ein bisschen sonstiger Kleinkram
und dann sollte das eigentlich auch schon alles gewesen sein.
Naja, so machen wir das, oder Pavel?
Ja, klingt wie ein Plan.
Gut, ja also die militärische Lage, was ist passiert.
Also zur Erinnerung, grundsätzlich ist es ja so, Russland bekämpft die Ukraine
derzeit vor allem im Osten der Ukraine.
Also primär im Oblast Donetsk, auch im Oblast Luhansk, theoretisch auch in Saporischia
und Kherson, aber da passiert eigentlich quasi überhaupt nichts.
Also, Ressorten gab es diesen kleinen Outpost in Krinki, über den wir auch schon
ein paar Mal gesprochen haben, wo nie so ganz klar war, was daraus werden würde.
Da hat sich jetzt die Ukraine zurückgezogen, mit anderen Worten,
da ist die Front komplett still.
Ähnlich ist es in Saporizia, also da stehen sich einfach die Truppen gegenüber,
aber keiner investiert da groß.
Und jetzt will Russland es irgendwie wissen und drängt sehr stark in der Region voran,
wo wir jetzt vor einem halben Jahr die Kämpfe um Avdivka beobachtet und auch
natürlich hier kommentiert haben.
Und nachdem die Ukrainer sich gezwungen sahen, Avdivka,
diesen Stronghold dort zu verlassen, weil einfach der Widerstand zu viel gekostet hätte,
seitdem verliert die Ukraine in diesem Bereich kontinuierlich ein Gebiet.
Und das ist schon wirklich eine sehr unangenehme Geschichte.
Ähnlich ist es etwas weiter im Norden.
Der Vorstoß auf Chassiv-Yar, das ist sozusagen die nächstwichtigere Stadt und
Position für die Ukraine hinter Bachmut.
Ja, der einjährige Kampf um Bachmut ist ja mit der Zerstörung der Stadt dann abgeschlossen.
Seitdem wollen die Russen halt auf Chassiviar vorstoßen und auch dort wird relativ
viel investiert durch die Russen. Investiert heißt halt immer...
Unglaublich viel Infanterie, die einfach nach vorne geschickt wird.
Verluste spielen keine Rolle.
In dieser Verteidigungsrolle hat zwar Ukraine generell die besseren Karten,
nur derzeit sieht halt der gesamte Front in etwa so aus.
Die Ukrainer halten halt ihre befestigten Stellung und die Russen greifen an
einerseits eben mit Infanterie,
aber vor allem mit diesen Gleitbombs, die so im letzten halben Jahr zu einem
richtig großen Problem geworden sind.
Denn erstens hat Russland da eine ganze Menge davon und zweitens können sie
die halt mit ihren Flugzeugen relativ geschützt im Rückraum absetzen und Gleitbombs heißt ja,
das sind quasi konventionelle Sprengkörper,
die aber nicht einfach nur abgeworfen werden,
sondern eben mit diesem zusätzlichen Rüstzug zu eben solchen gleitenden Bomben
umgebaut werden für wenig Geld und die segeln dann halt langsam ins Ziel.
Da bedeutet das, dass die Flugzeuge halt relativ hoch fliegen müssen,
um die dann aus größerer Distanz absegeln zu können.
Aber das sind halt sehr große Bomben, bis zu 500 Kilogramm Sprengkraft oder
ich glaube es gibt sogar noch größere.
Und da sie da so viel von haben und da sie da auch so viel von zum Einsatz bringen,
bedeutet das, dass einfach die Verteidigungsstellungen der Ukrainer gnadenlos bombardiert werden,
Bis halt auch vielleicht existierende Gebäude schlicht einfach nicht mehr existieren
und dann würden die Verluste zu groß werden und dann entscheidet sich halt die
Ukraine immer eher wieder Gebiet freizugeben und sich zurückzuziehen.
Als jetzt wirklich auf Biegen und Brechen jeden Meter zu halten.
Ich fand das ganz interessant, es gibt so eine Betrachtungsperspektive,
dass man eigentlich immer so ein Dreieck von drei Größenordnung hat.
Entweder du hast Gelände oder du hast Personal oder du hast irgendwie Ressourcen,
die du jeweils opfern musst, um in irgendeiner Form Widerstand zu leisten in
so einem Verteidigungskrieg.
Aber du musst dich halt für irgendwas entscheiden.
Und die Ukrainer setzen halt mehr darauf, ihr Personal zu schützen,
also nicht so viel Tote und Verletzte zu haben.
Und da sie es eben mit Ressourcen nicht beliebig kompensieren können,
müssen sie es eben mit Geländefreigabe kompensieren.
Und das ist halt, sagen wir mal, in den letzten zwei Monaten auch wirklich sehr
deutlich geworden, insbesondere in diesem Gebiet um Avdivka,
dass die Ukrainer Schritt für Schritt zurückgehen und sich alle halt denken,
wie lange kann das halt noch so weitergehen.
Das ist halt auch nichts, was jetzt in irgendeiner Form die Ukraine besonders bevorteilt oder so,
sie verlieren halt die ganze Zeit Gebiet, können ihre Personalstärke noch halbwegs hoch halten.
Aber nach Sieg sieht das dann halt nicht aus.
Und dieser Stellungskrieg ist halt dadurch, dass so viel Beobachtung stattfindet
und dieser Drohnenkrieg sich an dieser Front zusätzlich noch mit abspielt,
irgendwie alternativlos.
Man kann da mit keiner anderen Strategie vorangehen. Also machen es die Russen
wie immer mit viel und mit diesen Gleitbomben und mit ihrer Rücksichtslosigkeit,
dass ihnen halt einfach personelle Verluste weitgehend egal sind,
können sie halt einfach draufhauen und gewinnen dann eben Gelände,
weil sie eben wiederum sehr viel Ressourcen verbrauchen und sehr viel Personal
verbrauchen und die Ukrainer machen es halt genau andersrum.
Und ja, das war so ein bisschen die Situation und das hat auch vor allem allgemein
zu so ein bisschen Frustration natürlich geführt, weil das motiviert natürlich
jetzt nicht gerade besonders,
wenn das das Einzige ist, was man vermelden kann im Land.
Und alle haben sich halt gefragt, okay, wie soll das jetzt weitergehen?
Was sind jetzt hier die Schritte?
Also seit Avtivka gefallen ist, haben die Russen in diesem Gebiet ungefähr 500
Quadratkilometer an Gebietsgewinn gemacht.
Das wird nochmal eine interessante Zahl werden, wenn wir über die andere Initiative sprechen.
Ja und in diesem Jahr glaube ich um die 1000,
also seit Anfang des Jahres, seit den letzten 10 Monaten irgendwie 1000 Quadratkilometer
haben die Russen dazu gewonnen.
Das waren die Zahlen, die ich so gehört habe. Ja, insgesamt genau.
Scheint realistisch zu sein und bei der Zahl jetzt an abgefeuerten Artilleriegranaten oder Bomben,
so ist Russlandfaktor so zwei bis vier überlegen,
je nach Gegend und bei der Zahl der Flugzeuge und so ebenfalls und Personal,
äh
verheizt Russland wahrscheinlich auch so zwischen zwei und acht Mal so viel
wie die Ukraine, was so Gefallene angeht.
Aber teilweise, also ich meine Russland von den Globaldaten her ist halt mehr
als dreimal so groß und wirtschaftlich mehr als dreimal,
deutlich mehr als dreimal so stark und hat halt eben auch noch diese ganzen
Stockpiles aus dem Kalten Krieg, Die da jetzt plus Nordkorea und Iran,
die da auch zuliefern, jetzt insbesondere auch mit Kurzstreckenraketen,
wohl iranische Kurzstreckenraketen, kommen wohl haufenweise zum Einsatz aus
dem Grund, Weil Iran denkt,
dass es die nicht brauchen wird, weil Israel viel zu weit weg ist,
als dass diese Kurzstreckenraketen dort irgendeinen Unterschied machen würden.
Und ja, die haben auch so 200 Kilogramm Sprengköpfe, ist also auch nicht ohne.
Und ein CEP von 30 Metern ist jetzt also nicht unbedingt Hightech,
aber mit so einem großen Sprengkopf trotzdem unangenehm genug.
So, all das kommt natürlich jetzt zusammen. Plus, dass die russische Luftwaffe
wahrscheinlich zwischen, ich weiß nicht, 10 und 50 Mal so viele Flugzeuge hat wie die Ukraine.
Und ja, das macht sich natürlich sichtbar.
Auf der anderen Seite hat die Ukraine natürlich den Vorteil,
sich zu verteidigen und damit halt mehr Verluste den Russen beizufügen.
Aber Faktor 3 reicht nicht.
Es muss mehr als Faktor 3 sein. Und teilweise erzielen sie das,
aber teilweise eben auch nur Faktor 2 oder so.
Und wenn sie nur doppelt so viele Russen töten, wie Ukrainer getötet werden,
werden sie verlieren. So auf Dauer. Ja, also wenn sich das einfach so weitergeht.
Das heißt, was wir jetzt auch sehen, es sind immer noch die Echos natürlich
von den sechs Monaten Lieferengpässen, die sich auch dazu geführt haben,
dass nicht nur jetzt die Ukraine weniger Material hatte, sondern auch mehr Personal
leiden musste unter den Russen.
Weil sie eben nicht mit der Feuerkraft antworten konnten, die es benötigt hätte.
Also letztlich, da kommen wir vielleicht auch später noch dazu,
war die Situation verzweifelt, sodass man jetzt auch den Einmarsch in Kursk
so ein bisschen auch aus Verzweiflung,
dass der aus Verzweiflung geboren wurde,
weil man irgendwie handeln musste,
weil man das nicht einfach so weiterlaufen lassen konnte.
Da kommen wir gleich zu. Also das ist eine vielschichtige Motivationslage, sagen wir es mal so.
Um das vielleicht erstmal vom aktuellen Lagebericht her abzuschließen,
also das war jetzt die Situation in Donetsk und halt so ein bisschen allgemein
etwas weiter nördlich in Luhansk gibt es geringe Gewinne hier und da,
aber es ist weitgehend halt Stillstand.
Auch dort eher größere russische Verluste, aber da konnten sich die Ukrainer halt behaupten.
Dann ist weiterhin die Krim ein beliebtes Ziel für ukrainische Drohnen und Raketenangriffe.
Die Russen müssen in der Krim weiterhin enorme Verluste hinnehmen.
Also wir haben ja schon viel über den gewonnenen Seekrieg gesprochen.
Und das manifestiert sich jetzt halt einfach darin, dass es mittlerweile auf
der Krim keine nennenswerten Kriegsschiffe mehr gibt.
Also alle größeren Kriegsschiffe, die jetzt wirklich kampffähig wären,
die sind dort nicht mehr. Man weiß natürlich nicht ganz genau,
wo jetzt die ganzen Unterseeboote sind.
Das ist ja nochmal so eine Eigenschaft von Unterseebooten. Von einem weiß man
es allerdings, das ist die Rostov-on-Don.
Die ist ja vor einigen Monaten schon beim Storm Shadow Angriff im Trocken-Dock
erheblich beschädigt worden.
Trotz alledem haben sich die Russen bemüht in den letzten Monaten die wieder
zu flicken und haben sie wohl so weit geflickt bekommen, dass sie sie wieder wassern konnten.
Dann hat sie also dieses Trocken-Dock verlassen, wurde aber dann vor zwei,
drei Wochen durch einen weiteren Drohnenangriff komplett versenkt und das war
es dann halt mit der Rostov-on-Don.
Also dieses U-Boot, das kann Russland jetzt abschreiben, was bei den anderen
ist, weiß man nicht so ganz genau.
Aber alle größeren Kriegsschiffe sind halt entweder in Novorossiysk,
also ganz weit im Osten des Schwarzen Meeres oder eben komplett abgezogen auch
im Asowschen Meer, wo es mal hieß, dass sie sich dahin zurückgezogen haben.
Sind sie wohl nicht, weil ihnen das dann schon wiederum zu nah an der Ukraine dran ist.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht gut gelaufen für die Russen.
Und es ist wirklich bemerkenswert, dass der Ukraine das gelungen ist.
Und es ist natürlich eine spezielle Situation so mit dem Schwarzen Meer.
Und die Türkei lässt auch keine weiteren russischen Schiffe rein,
sodass sie die auch nicht so ohne weiteres ersetzen können.
Und politisch natürlich stellt es die ganze Krim-Situation so ein bisschen in Frage,
weil ja eine wichtige Motivation für Russland war,
dass sie von der Krim aus dann mit ihren Schiffen das Schwarze Meer irgendwie
beherrschen oder kontrollieren wollten.
Und ja, solange dieser Krieg jetzt läuft so,
kann Russland eigentlich die Krim als Militärbasis mehr oder weniger abschreiben. Ja, richtig.
In Odessa sieht das jetzt übrigens so aus, dass dort ein mehr oder weniger normaler
Hafenverkehr stattfindet. Also dort wird wirklich Getreide verschifft.
Das hat nicht so ganz die Kapazität, wie das vielleicht früher mal war,
aber so auf 50 Prozent fährt das alles schon. Da sind also relativ viele Schiffe
vor Anker und werden auch beladen und verlassen wieder den Hafen.
Es gibt zwar immer noch relativ viele Angriffe auf Odessa, aber nichtsdestotrotz, dort passiert was.
Da gibt es natürlich bei den Rädern international noch etwas Zurückhaltung,
weil Krisengebiet und dann ist es halt auch teuer, dafür eine Crew zu finden.
Aber das ist etwas, was man sich klar machen muss immer wieder,
dass es der Ukraine wirklich gelungen ist, die Russen im Schwarzen Meer komplett
zu verdrängen und diese Bedrohung des Hafen Odessas zumindest soweit in den Griff zu bekommen,
um wieder Business machen zu können.
Außerdem haben sie ja noch diverse Zugverbindungen und Hafennutzungen in anderen
Ländern, Griechenland etc.
Das hatten wir auch, glaube ich, mal angesprochen jeweils, als es ausgehandelt wurde.
Wie sehr das so zum Einsatz kommt, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber es wurde generell
viel daran gearbeitet, die Eisenbahnverbindungen in den Westen auszubauen, besser zu machen etc.
Und grundsätzlich hat man so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass die Militärische
Aktivität auf der Krim, die die Ukraine dort veranlasst,
das hat alles so diesen Charakter von Shaping-Operationen.
Also es wird gezielt Luftverteidigung angegangen und man muss nicht viel rechnen können,
um sich auszumalen, dass das natürlich auch eine Vorbereitung sein kann auf,
Tja, und dann wissen wir es nicht genau.
Also entweder ein Angriff auf die Krimbrücke oder eben auch eine Invasion der
Krim, wie auch immer sich die Ukraine das gedacht hat, weiß man nicht, wir schon gar nicht.
Trotz alledem, das ist das, was dort stattfindet.
Ja, dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal auf die Kharkiv-Offensive der Russen kurz eingehen.
Im Mai ging das los.
Das war ja sozusagen diese Aktion, wo die Russen dann eine neue Front aufgemacht
haben mit Stoßrichtung Kharkiv, also der Stadt Kharkiv, nicht nur in dem Oblast Kharkiv.
Die aber dann von den Ukrainern relativ schnell eingehegt werden konnte.
Also sie sind halt da bis zu dieser kleinen Stadt Wofchansk vorgestoßen und
dort war dann eigentlich auch schon im wesentlichen Ende für die Russen.
Derzeit ist auch da die Frontlinie eher so im Stillstand, also da bewegt sich
gerade nicht sehr viel, aber das war jetzt für die Russen kein besonderer Gewinn.
Also das ist so ein 100 Quadrat oder 200 Quadratkilometer Gebiet,
was sie da so de facto überrannt haben,
aber das war halt dann auch so, dass eigentlich die Russen so nennenswert über
die erste Verteidigungsstellung der Ukrainer auch nicht hinausgekommen ist.
Am Anfang gab es ja sehr viel Aufregung, dass sie da überhaupt erstmal ins Land
rein konnten und warum denn die Grenze nicht gesichert ist.
Das Ding ist, man braucht halt immer so eine Pufferzone. Man kann ja nicht direkt
an der Grenze anfangen irgendwas aufzubauen, weil dann hat man es einfach sofort
mit Artillerie und mit Drohnenangriffen zu tun.
Dementsprechend sind halt die eigentlichen Verteidigungslinien ein bisschen
weiter hinten. Das ist auch bei den Russen nicht sehr viel anders,
wie wir gleich noch sehen werden.
Auf jeden Fall, auch das ist sehr verlustreich und das ist wohl sogar noch verlustreicher
als in den anderen Gebieten.
Die Ukraine spricht davon, dass hier so das Verlustverhältnis von 1 zu 8 ist, so mit anderen Worten.
Diese ganze Offensive war für die Russen jetzt kein großer Gewinn und ich glaube
wir haben auch schon letztes Mal darüber gesprochen, dass es vor allem auch
in einer Hinsicht ein echter Verlust war.
Weil erinnern wir uns nochmal, nachdem das kam, wurden die Auflagen für die
Nutzung von amerikanischen Waffen und auch deutschen Waffen im russischen Grenzgebiet
schon mal deutlich gelockert.
Weil es war dann irgendwie offensichtlich, dass eine Verschlimmerung der Situation
einfach nie akzeptabel war und da kam dann auf einmal etwas Bewegung in diese
permanente Abstimmung zwischen den westlichen Kräften,
ihrem Support und was sie eben der Ukraine noch erlauben oder wo sie nicht mit
Einschränkungen belegen.
Also offiziell dürften sie danach bis zu 100 Kilometer rein nach Russland Angriffe
durchführen auf militärische Ziele.
So, also das ist, glaube ich, oder ist auch bisher noch die offizielle Doktrin,
die jetzt für, insbesondere für Attackams gilt.
Und was jetzt Storm Shadows anging, gab es ja so einen Hickhack hin und her
und am Ende haben die Engländer dann aber dann doch,
gesagt, dass im Prinzip für die Storm Shadows dasselbe gilt wie für die Attackams.
Nachdem sie zwischenzeitlich anderes behauptet hatten.
Also da geht auch viel hin und her, aber es war auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr
interessant zu sehen, dass da kamen die Dinge auf einmal in Bewegung und das
wird gleich nochmal eine Rolle spielen.
Nach einer Weile gab es dann auch Warnungen von der Ukraine,
da haben sie sich öffentlich zu geäußert. Ich glaube, das kam so hier aus dem Budanov-Bereich.
Also Budanov ist der Chef des Militärnachrichtendienstes der Ukraine.
Die sind so für diese ganzen Geheimoperationen zuständig. Auch ein sehr junger
Typ, Baujahr 86, der auch schon so ein Kult nach sich zieht.
Nach dem Salushny, dem ehemaligen Chef des Militärs, der ja sehr populär war in der Ukraine,
ist also vor allem dieser Budanov, glaube ich, wirklich einer der populärsten Typen,
weil er einfach krasse Aktionen plant und auch in seinem ganzen Auftreten einfach wirklich eine Show ist,
weil er einfach immer sein Cool bewahrt.
Also der hat einfach eine coole Erscheinung, das macht wirklich Eindruck auf die Bevölkerung.
Nichtsdestotrotz, es gab halt diese Warnung, so ein Vorstoß wie die Russen das
in der Kharkiv-Region gemacht haben, das wäre auch im Oblast Sumi denkbar.
Und dementsprechend hat man sich auf einen solchen Vorstoß vorbereitet.
Mental wie auch militärisch.
Ja.
Zwischendurch gab es dann natürlich auch weiterhin die fortgesetzten Drohnenangriffe
auf Russland, über die wir ja auch schon gesprochen haben, auf Öllager und auf Ölraffinerien.
Es wird permanent irgendwas bombardiert und mittlerweile haben die Russen ein echtes Problem da.
Also es wird fast kaum noch Diesel und Benzin exportiert, sondern es gibt da
einen richtigen Exportstopp sogar.
Ja, den haben sie jetzt bis Ende des Jahres verlängert, so aktuell gerade.
Und dann eben auch Weißrussland aufgefordert, auch nur noch an Russland zu liefern
jetzt bei Raffinerieprodukten und wollen dann auch aus anderen Nachbarländern,
Kasachstan und so, die Importe erhöhen.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Also Russland mit diesen riesigen Ölreserven,
eines der ressourcenkräftigsten Länder überhaupt,
was jetzt fossile Energie betrifft, ist auf einmal nicht mehr in der Lage seinen
eigenen Diesel- und Benzinbedarf zu decken.
Das ist definitiv eine Folge dieser Angriffe.
Das erlaubt keine andere Erklärung.
Ja, wobei die Produktion wohl offiziell nur, in Anführungszeichen,
um 10 bis 20 Prozent reduziert wurde.
Also viele der Raffinerien konnten auch relativ schnell wieder online gebracht werden.
Aber ja, nichtsdestotrotz haben auch die 10% mittlerweile spürbare Auswirkungen.
Die Benzinpreise in Russland wurden mehrmals erhöht.
Die sind ja staatlich garantiert. Es wird ja auch subventioniert,
das Benzin und der Diesel für die Bevölkerung wird also unter Herstellungskosten
sowieso abgegeben und der russische
Staat zahlt dann Subventionen an die Mineralölfirmen, abhängig davon,
so wie viel billiger sie das Ganze jetzt unter Marktpreis dann abgeben.
Und ja, das sieht nicht gut aus, aber ich gucke halt immer und überlege,
wenn die Russen bei dem relativ...
Vergleichsweise geringeren Anzahl an Drohnenangriffen so sehr in der Bredouille ist,
was die Ukraine da eigentlich erdulden muss mit ihren Angriffen auf vor allem
ihre Strominfrastruktur in erster Linie.
Und was jetzt aber angesichts auch,
also seit dem Einmarsch in Kursk, hat wohl die Ukraine jetzt von Lager und Raffinerien,
haben sie sich auf Flugplätze konzentriert, gerade mit ihren Langstrecken-Drohnen.
Und haben dort wohl vorgestern einen der größten kombinierten Drohnenangriffe
gestartet mit irgendwie über 100 Drohnen, die sie auf den Weg gebracht haben gleichzeitig.
Also weshalb man erwartet, dass sie jetzt ein bisschen runterfahren müssen in nächster Zeit. Ja.
Das mit den Drohnen ist nochmal ein ganz interessanter Punkt,
weil die Ukraine hat hier offensichtlich das erste Mal auch wirklich einen militärischen
Vorteil sich erarbeitet.
Mittlerweile produziert die Ukraine also Millionen an Drohnen.
Ich habe es gerade wieder vergessen, was das Produktionsziel für dieses Jahr
war, aber es war hoch bis Ende des Jahres, irgendwie 10 Millionen oder sowas.
Also sie gehen sozusagen in die Vollproduktion.
Und das haben sie eben ermöglicht, indem sie viele kleine Startups auch ermutigt
haben, da mit eigenen Entwicklungen einherzugehen.
Mit anderen Worten, sie haben nicht nur viele Drohnen, sondern sie haben auch
viele unterschiedliche Drohnen, spezialisiert auf die einzelnen Bereiche.
Sie haben Langstreckendrohnen, Kurzstreckendrohnen, FPV, Kamikaze,
Überwachungsdrohnen, alles produzieren sie so weit es irgendwie möglich ist im Land selber.
Und scheinen dabei aber auch wirklich gute Fortschritte zu machen.
Es gibt da die Klage aus russischen Kreisen, also man kriegt das so mit aus
abgehörten russischen Kommentaren und was sie auf Telegram schreiben etc.,
dass das also wirklich mittlerweile eine Übermacht darstellt.
Sprich im Bereich Drohnen kann es sein, dass das Verhältnis kippt und man sieht
das eben auch bei diesen ganzen Angriffen.
Ich meine, die zerstören teilweise Ziele, die 2.000, 3.000 Kilometer von der Ukraine entfernt sind.
Die haben einen Flugplatz angegriffen oben bei Norwegen, also auf Höhe von,
ich habe gerade den Flugplatz vergessen, aber da wo Langstreckenbomber stationiert
sind, die also super, super weit weg sind und...
Russland hat überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit mit dem, was sie noch an Luftabwehrsystemen
zur Verfügung haben, ihr ganzes Land abzudecken.
Also wenn sie mit ihren Drohnen es irgendwie über einen gewissen kritischen
Bereich schaffen, fliegen die einfach ewig weiter und finden auch ihre Ziele.
Und das wird natürlich jetzt für die Russen zu einem richtigen Problem.
Und genauso ist es wohl so, dass hier die Russen wiederum ein Problem haben
und zwar in zweierlei Hinsicht. Erstens, also wir versuchen natürlich auch an
Drohnen ranzukommen, weil es ist nun mal ein Drohnenkrieg, den wir jetzt hier haben.
Aber auf der einen Seite haben sie wohl Schwierigkeiten, Quantität und Qualität
aus China zu bekommen, insbesondere Qualität, weil die zahlen halt jetzt jeden
Preis und die Chinesen lassen die da so ein bisschen auch an der langen Hand verhungern.
Und oft ist halt die Technik, die da ankommt, dann auch nicht so toll.
Und abgesehen davon rächt sich natürlich dann auch ein weiteres Mal die interne
Korruption der russischen Armee, weil natürlich jetzt auch große Unternehmen dann versuchen,
diese Drohnenproduktion an sich zu reißen.
Und kleine Startups, so wie die Ukraine das macht, die also schnell auch auf
diesen technologischen Fortschritt reagieren könnten, die haben halt irgendwie keine Chance.
Und es ist ein permanenter Battle. Alle paar Monate ändern sich die Vorzeichen,
wie Electronic Warfare funktioniert, wie man eben optimiert.
Jetzt geht es in Richtung KI-gesteuerte Drohnen,
die dann eben nicht mehr so Electronic Warfare-mäßig anfällig sein sollen wollen
und jetzt auch aus dem Kursangriff hört man, dass es hier schon ein paar neue
Entwicklungen gibt, wie zum Beispiel.
Die erste Drohne, die ein Hubschrauber erlegt hat. Aber damit sind wir im Prinzip
dann auch beim Hauptthema, nämlich der Kursoffensive der Ukraine,
die glaube ich alle komplett auf dem linken Fuß erwischt hat.
Nicht nur uns und Russland, sondern auch die USA und die Welt und alle Analysten,
was es passiert. Also am 5.
August, also mittlerweile vor elf Tagen, während wir hier drüber reden,
rückt eine ukrainische Brigade auf das Territorium bei Sumi vor.
Genau das Sumi, wo sie vorher gewarnt haben, dass da ja vielleicht die Russen angreifen könnten.
Und mich beschleicht so der Gedanke, dass diese Warnung gar nicht so sehr was
mit Truppenkonzentrationen zu tun hat, die es dort gab,
weil die gab es offensichtlich nicht, sondern das Ganze war eher so eine Nebelkerze,
die die Ukraine gestartet hat, um damit abzudecken, dass sie wiederum Truppen
konzentrieren. Das ist das eine.
Das andere ist, dass sie wohl auch viel Truppenkonzentration dadurch erzielt
haben, dass Militär in diese Region nach Sumi gegangen ist, aber nicht in die
Kasernen, sondern privat untergekommen sind.
Das heißt, sie haben sehr viel Soldaten und Material zusammengezogen,
ohne dass sich das für die Russen so ohne weiteres beobachten ließ.
Gut, am Ende waren da auch viele Panzer, sonstige Fahrzeuge.
Das lässt sich natürlich auch nur begrenzt verbergen und es gab wohl auch entsprechende
Meldungen innerhalb des russischen Militärapparats, ob denn da nicht irgendwie was im Busche wäre.
Aber es heißt, dass Gerasimov,
der Leiter des Militärs, diese ganzen Warnungen nicht ernst genommen hat und
so war es dann halt möglich,
dass die Ukrainer hier völlig überraschend die Grenze überrollt haben.
Und sie sind dann halt rüber über den ersten Grenzübergang und dann ging alles
sehr schnell und die ersten zwei Verteidigungslinien, die es dort gibt,
das ist nämlich relativ nah an der Grenze und dann nochmal ein,
zwei Kilometer hinter der Grenze, dort haben sie halt so ein Trench-Network
gezogen, die wurden mehr oder weniger sofort überlaufen.
Und auf einmal standen die Ukrainer vor der Stadt Sucha, die da relativ nah
an der Grenze gelegen ist und dann hat es auch nicht lange gedauert und sie
hatten diese Stadt unter Kontrolle. Wie haben sie das gemacht?
Sie haben eine konzertierte Aktion losgetreten, wo wirklich alle Verbände zusammengearbeitet haben.
Ganz zu Beginn, ganz vorne sind sie mit Drohneneinheiten vorangeschritten,
die halt also 10, 20 Kilometer weit ins Land quasi mit ihren Drohnen schon mal reinschießen konnten.
Und die dann mit entsprechenden, ich weiß nicht genau wie sie es gemacht haben,
also entweder mit Granatenabwürfen oder mit Kamikazedrohnen diesen ersten Stellungen,
die eh dünn besetzt waren,
da schon mal Angst eingejagt haben.
Dann sind die alle erstmal in Entdeckung gegangen und dann sind sie parallel
dazu mit schnell fahrenden Infanterieeinheiten losgegangen und haben dann dieses
Überraschungsmoment, weil die ja natürlich alle total überrascht waren,
die wussten, ob nicht was los ist,
ausgenutzt und haben dann diese Truppen relativ schnell übertölpeln können.
Und so ist es dann den Ukrainern gelungen, innerhalb von ein,
zwei Tagen schon ein riesiges Gebiet in irgendeiner Form unter ihre Kontrolle zu bringen.
Dem sind dann noch diverse weitere Einheiten gefolgt, das heißt dann sind sie
mit schweren Geräten, mit Panzern, mit allen möglichen Versorgungsfahrzeugen, Logistik etc.
Gefolgt und haben nach hinten dann alles abgesichert. Und das ging einfach schnell.
Warum ging das so schnell?
Naja, weil die Russen erstens überrascht waren und zweitens dort komplett unterbesetzt waren.
Und sie hatten vor allem auch überhaupt gar keine besonders ausgebildete Truppe
dort am Start, sondern das war eher so eine Region, die sie mit Wehrpflichtigen besetzt haben.
Also da standen irgendwelche 18,
19-Jährigen rum und auf einmal kamen die Ukrainer mit ihrer ganzen Power.
Ja und dazu ist wohl auch so, dass sie halt viel natürlich die Russen auch auf Kameras gesetzt haben,
die die Grenze überwachen und da ist es wohl der Ukraine auch gelungen zum einen
dieses Kameranetzwerk auszuschalten plus dann den Funk der Russen auch zu stören,
sodass sie erst mal überhaupt Schwierigkeiten hatten, sich ein Bild zu machen,
wo denn genau was passiert.
Und sie scheinen dann auch in der Lage gewesen zu sein, die russischen Drohnen
erfolgreich zu stören in dem Gebiet, dass die Russen einfach erst mal blind waren.
Und dann...
Psychologisch, was wohl auch dazu kam, ist dann so ein bisschen der Effekt,
dass man erstmal das nicht geglaubt hat,
was da vor sich geht, weil es einfach ein bisschen außerhalb ihrer Vorstellungskraft lag.
Weil dazu sollten die Ukrainer eigentlich nicht fähig und in der Lage sein.
Und das kann nicht sein, was nicht, ja darf nicht sein, was nicht sein kann.
Und das spielte sicherlich auch eine Rolle dafür.
Plus noch ein paar andere interessante Faktoren, die wir dann vielleicht aber
hinterher nochmal bei der politischen Bewertung oder bei den weiteren Reaktionen
der Bevölkerung beispielsweise,
die halt auch ganz anders reagiert hat,
als umgekehrt als die Russen in die Ukraine rein sind und sich die Ukrainer
dann mit allem bewaffnet haben,
dessen sie handhaben und spontan sich dann zu Territorialverteidigungsgruppen
zusammengefunden haben.
Und das hat man auf der russischen Seite gar nicht gesehen.
Und da gibt es, glaube ich, auch gute Gründe für, warum das so anders ist.
Aber ja, vielleicht nochmal so ein paar Zahlen, denke ich, konkret welchen Umfang das Ganze hat.
Also die Ukraine ist wohl jetzt mit mindestens vier Brigaden unterwegs,
was so 4.000 bis 6.000 Soldaten etwa entsprechen soll, mit denen sie reingegangen sind.
Plus dann nochmal 2.000 bis 4.000 Kräfte dann im Bereich Sumi auf der eigenen
Seite, die dann für Logistik und Luftverteidigung zuständig sind.
Also wir reden von 5.000 bis 10.000.
Das ist eine große Spannbreite, aber das ist auf jeden Fall groß.
Eine signifikante Menge an Truppen und Ressourcen, die sie committed haben.
Und wenn ich das richtig verfolgt habe,
dann haben sie, also es gibt so diese eine größere Straße, die von der Ukraine
nach Sucha reinführt, diese H0-7.
Die waren natürlich am
besten gesichert und weshalb die
Ukraine dann nördlich und südlich von der H-07 über die Grenze gegangen sind
und eingesickert sind und dann die Hauptbefestigungsstellung auf der H-07 von
hinten aufgerollt haben.
Und dabei dann auch entsprechend Gefangene gemacht haben und damit dann,
sagen wir, diese wichtige Straße dort auch einfach freimachen konnten.
H07 heißt sie in der Ukraine, in Russland ist es dann die R200.
Ah, okay. Und insgesamt sind sie da aber auch auf einer Breite von 30 Kilometern
ungefähr über die Grenze gegangen.
Das heißt, es war jetzt nicht nur eine punktuelle Incursion,
sondern es ist schon 60 Kilometer entlang der Grenze und dann bis zu 30 Kilometer
tief im Schnitt nach Russland vorgestoßen.
Und allerdings nicht überall,
sondern bisher war das Ganze noch relativ zackig oder ausgefranst und da wird
sich sicherlich noch einiges konsolidieren.
Und die letzten Zahlen, die wir jetzt hatten, was das flächenmäßig ausmacht,
sind wohl 1150 Quadratkilometer.
So sind die letzten Zahlen.
Und dann sagt es 160.000 Fußballfelder oder 0,4 Saarland.
0,4 Saarland, genau. Saarland ist immer so das Maß.
Aber ich sage ja eins, kein Mensch weiß, wie groß das Saarland eigentlich ist.
Und deswegen kann man sich vielleicht das ganz gut so vorstellen.
Die Fläche entspricht tatsächlich ziemlich genau der Gesamtfläche von Berlin.
Plus Potsdam. Das ist also in etwa das Gebiet, von dem wir reden,
natürlich nicht in demselben Maße bewohnt, sondern hier gibt es nur ein paar Kleckersiedlungen.
Sie haben mittlerweile glaube ich so an die 82 Siedlungen unter ihrer Kontrolle.
Und nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich signifikant, weil ihr erinnert euch vielleicht
hier am Anfang der Sendung, haben wir mal kurz zusammengefasst,
was denn die Russen in diesem Jahr alles so erobert haben und das ist halt in einer Woche mehr,
als die Russen jetzt seit Anfang dieses Jahres der Ukraine abgenommen haben.
Das rechnet sich natürlich jetzt nicht wirklich gegen, aber nur um mal so ein
Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was jetzt hier eigentlich gerade passiert.
Also wir reden hier nicht über so einen kleinen Überfall, sondern die Ukrainer
haben jetzt hier ihre Strategie geändert und sehr schnell sehr große Erfolge
erzielt und wir sind noch lange nicht am Ende dieser Geschichte.
Im Prinzip geht es jetzt gerade so in die dritte Phase über und da ist noch
alles offen, weil die Russen fangen jetzt eigentlich erst an, sich zu verteidigen.
Natürlich haben sie jetzt irgendwelche Truppen vorgeschickt und es gibt an den
Gebieten, wo jetzt der Einfluss der Ukraine erstmal ändert, gibt es natürlich
auch Kämpfe, aber täglich werden weitere Geländegewinne gemeldet.
So in der Größenordnung von ein, zwei Kilometer hier und da.
Und außerdem ist die Zahl von jetzt schon in Gefangenschaft geratenen Russen,
die auch teilweise einfach aufgegeben haben, sehr hoch.
Also man geht von über 2000 Gefangenen aus, das ist extrem viel und es ist glaube
ich schon relativ klar, dass der Stachel auch tief sitzt,
weil die Russen jetzt selber schon anfangen über Gefangenenaustausch zu reden.
Normalerweise lassen die sich immer bitten.
Und ja, das Problem ist vor allem,
dass es sich hier halt um Wehrpflichtige handelt und das macht sehr viel mehr
Ärger in der Bevölkerung als irgendwelche Kontraktdienst, die also sich Geld dafür bezahlen lassen,
ihren Schädel da hinzuhalten. Das ist für sie ein Problem.
Außerdem müssen sie jetzt sehr viele Truppen verlegen und das dauert.
Weil, wo haben sie denn ihre Truppen?
Ja, im Osten und im Süden der Ukraine.
Das heißt, um aktive Truppen dorthin zu bekommen, müssen sie die jetzt alle
in die Eisenbahn und in Lastwagen setzen und ein paar tausend Kilometer im Kreis
schicken, bis die überhaupt erstmal in Kurs ankommen.
Weil aus dem Land selber heraus können sie nicht so ohne weiteres Truppen generieren,
Weil alles das, was sie generieren, haben sie sowieso schon nach Donetsk geschickt.
Und das ist für die Russen ein weiteres Problem.
Reden wir vielleicht nochmal kurz über...
Das Ziel als solches. Warum dort? Also warum hat die Ukraine dort angegriffen?
Wenn man sich das geografisch anschaut, ist es natürlich vor allem erstmal deshalb
interessant, weil es sehr weit weg von der sonstigen Frontlinie ist.
Und gerade wenn die Russen jetzt gezwungen sind zu verlegen,
ist man natürlich am liebsten so weit weg, wie es irgendwie geht.
Man hat noch so einen gewissen Achtungsabstand zu Belarus, aber im Prinzip ist
auf jeden Fall alles, wo die Russen gut aufgestellt sind, relativ weit weg.
Dazu kommt, dass dieser Ort Sucha, den sie sich als erstes geschnappt haben,
auch ganz interessant aus strategischen, logistischen Gründen ist.
Einerseits führt dort eine wichtige Bahnlinie durch,
die insbesondere für die Verstärkung der in Belgorod stationierten Truppen wichtig
ist für Dinge, die aus Belarus kommen.
Und ist natürlich auch ein wichtiger Teil einfach des Eisenbahnnetzes und das
führt schon mal zu einer Menge Umleitungen.
Außerdem beherbergt Sucha eine wichtige Gaspumpstation, das ist nämlich quasi
der Ort, wo das Gas, was dann durch die Pipeline in der Ukraine geht,
Richtung Ungarn und Slowakei gepumpt wird.
Das scheint gerade so zu sein, dass dieser Ort jetzt,
na ich weiß nicht, ob er komplett zerstört ist, aber er ist zumindest bombardiert
worden und zwar von den Russen, weil die Ukrainer den eingenommen haben und
die Russen es dann erstmal für eine gute Idee gehalten haben,
da ein paar Bomben drauf zu schmeißen. Und...
Außerdem war Sucha auch noch ein militärisch wichtiger Platz.
Da gab es so ein paar FSB-Zentralen etc. Das weiß ich im Detail alles nicht so genau.
Auf jeden Fall, der Stachel sitzt da schon relativ tief.
Also dafür, dass es so nah an der Grenze war, war das also ein strategisch wichtiger Ort.
Also es gab dort halt ein Kommando-Osten der Armee und auch des Geheimdienstes.
Und weil die Ukrainer aber so schnell vorgerückt sind, haben es die Militärs
und Geheimdienstler nicht geschafft, so dort alles rauszuschaffen.
Und weil normalerweise passiert das nicht.
Normalerweise sind diese Kommandostellen hinreichend weit von der Front entfernt,
dass wenn man sieht, der Feind rückt nahe, dann verlegt man ihn zurück.
Weil das ist halt einfach, das passiert ganz selten, dass sowas in die Hände des Feindes fällt.
Und ja, also da gab es halt wirklich lustige Clips von ukrainischen Soldaten,
die da in der russischen Kommandostelle sitzen und nachspielen,
wie die Russen irgendwie...
Prigozhin sich bei den Militärführern beschwert.
Wo bleibt Putin? Wo bleibt die Munition?
Und einen Riesenspaß haben, sozusagen in diesen brussischen Kommandoposten zu
sitzen mit altem Telefon am Ohr und dann Putin, wo bleibt die Munition?
Und sich dabei wirklich totlachen.
Also ein bisschen Spaß in dieser ernsten Situation ist da auch dringend erforderlich.
Und der Moralboost für die Ukrainer und die ukrainische Armee ist natürlich
auch gewaltig dadurch. Also viele...
Kämpfer haben dann gesagt, er meinte, ich fühle mich wie ein Tiger.
Allein die Meme, die in den ersten Tagen so aufgekommen sind online,
ich habe schreiend, voll lachend zusammengesunken.
So irgendwie, ja, Russland 2024, zweitbeste Armee in Russland und das Beste
überhaupt halt dieser bekannte Memeclip aus Herr der Ringe so,
one can simply walk into Mordor.
Ja, in der Tat richtig gut und dann gab es dann natürlich auch die Witze,
um irgendwie das jetzt ein Referendum veranstalten werden,
sozusagen, ob die Leute sich nicht lieber der Ukraine anschließen wollen.
Es ist immer ganz interessant, es gibt ja jetzt in zunehmendem Maße so Clips,
Gespräche auch mit der Bevölkerung und ein Teil der Bevölkerung ist ja geflohen,
manche sind aber auch geblieben.
Die Ukraine sorgt mittlerweile selber mit Hilfslieferungen dafür,
dass die eben auch was zu essen haben Und zu trinken haben, weil natürlich ist
die Infrastruktur jetzt auch weitgehend zusammengebrochen.
Und was ich ganz interessant fand, ist, dass in dieser Region die Leute nicht
einfach nur russisch sprechen,
sondern dass da sehr viele zu sein scheinen, die tatsächlich entweder ukrainisch
sprechen oder so ein Zwischendialekt, ich hab jetzt gerade den Namen vergessen davon,
der so eine Mischung aus russisch und ukrainisch ist, der wohl in dieser Region
durchaus auch verbunden ist. verbreitet ist.
Und so die Bevölkerung hat gar nicht so die Probleme da mit den ukrainischen
Soldaten und überhaupt ist da auch die Auseinandersetzung natürlich ein bisschen anders,
weil im Gegensatz zu den Russen fangen sie halt nicht an, gleich die Bevölkerung
zu foltern und alle umzubringen.
Noch vielleicht zu Sucha noch, also das war halt auch oder ist eine wichtige
Zentrale auch im Hinblick auf das Eisenbahnsystem und ich habe es noch nicht so ganz durchdrungen,
aber die Möglichkeit dort auf die Bahninfrastruktur zuzugreifen,
erlaubt es Ihnen wohl auch Zugbewegungen an anderen Stellen mit zu protokollieren?
Also sie haben da sozusagen auch einen IT-Zugang erhalten.
Das hat sowas mit, wie das Signalisierungssystem dort funktioniert.
Das können die Russen nicht einfach ausschalten, dass die das da auch sehen können.
Und ja, müssen wir nochmal schauen, was das so für Konsequenzen hat.
Aber auch über Sucha hinaus ist natürlich die Region ganz interessant und was
natürlich von Anfang an in der Diskussion stand, ist, dass mittlerweile auch nur noch weitere 20,
30 Kilometer von der aktuellen Frontlinie entfernte Atomkraftwerk Kursk in der Nähe der Stadt Kursk.
Und das ist auch jetzt mal nicht ein kleines Ding, sondern dieses Atomkraftwerk
versorgt halt nicht nur die Stadt Kursk und die Region, sondern auch relativ
wichtige Industriebereiche.
Unter anderem liefert das also die Energie, die die Produktion von 30% der Eisenproduktion
Russlands und ein Großteil auch der Nahrungsmittelproduktion absichert.
Mit anderen Worten, das ist für die Russen ein echtes Problem,
dass dieses Atomkraftwerk auch nur unter der Bedrohung der Ukrainer steht.
Bisher macht es nicht so den Eindruck, als ob die Ukrainer jetzt ein großes
Interesse daran hätten, auf Biegen und Brechen zu diesem Atomkraftwerk vorzustoßen.
Aber das müssen sie halt auch gar nicht, weil die Russen müssen es jetzt eh verteidigen.
Das heißt, sie müssen auf jeden Fall da sehr viel Aufwand schon mal leisten, um dort sicher zu sein.
Und die Ukrainer können sich im Prinzip jetzt gerade auch aussuchen,
in welche Richtung sie vorstoßen, weil insbesondere der westliche Bereich ist
natürlich sehr schlecht versorgt.
Aber im Prinzip können sie und versuchen sie auch gerade in alle Richtungen
dieses Gebiet weiter auszubauen und ich wäre jetzt nicht so überrascht,
wenn wir also diese Zahl von 1150 Quadratkilometern, dass die sich in den nächsten
Tagen und vielleicht auch Wochen noch weiter erhöht, bis die Russen überhaupt mal in der Lage sind,
ausreichend Druck auszuüben, um die Ukraine auch wieder zurückzudrängen.
Ja, also grundsätzlich fand das so eine interessante Analyse.
So, Frage, wohin geht's denn, was ist denn das Ziel?
Gab so eine schöne Phasenanalyse, also generell so eine Invasion oder so eine
Offensive. besteht dann halt aus vier Phasen so.
Erstmal den Break-In, also den ersten Einbruch.
Dann den tatsächlichen Durchbruch, der sich halt vom Einbruch dadurch unterscheidet,
dass man halt sich einen freien Weg geschaffen hat durch die Verteidigungsstellungen.
Dann die dritte Phase, also die ersten beiden Phasen sind im Prinzip am ersten
Tag passiert und dann hat,
die Ausnutzung eine Exploitation-Phase begonnen, die noch läuft und gerade wahrscheinlich
in die Konsolidierungsphase übergeht,
womit dann typischerweise so eine Offensive endet. Also man,
quasi ja konsolidiert.
Also Exploitation nicht jetzt der Ressourcen oder der Bevölkerung,
sondern sozusagen der Gelegenheit, weiter Geländegewinde zu machen.
Ja, also genau, dann das offene Gelände auszunutzen,
um dann entsprechend strategisch wichtige Punkte zu besetzen oder dann eben
ja Gefangene zu machen oder Waffen,
Munition zu erobern oder auch Dinge zu zerstören unterwegs.
Also all diese Dinge gehören halt zur Exploitation.
Und die Konsolidierung ist dann, dass man halt Befestigungsstellungen schafft.
Und ich hatte auch gesehen, dass die Ukrainer sich eingraben.
Am Anfang war die Frage, okay, sind sie jetzt nur rein und ziehen sich jetzt
wieder schnell zurück? Oder wollen sie das andere Extrem, das Ganze als Faustband
für Verhandlungen behalten?
Oder eine dritte Möglichkeit, irgendwas dazwischen, dass sie sich zwar nicht
sofort zurückziehen, aber das Ganze nutzen,
um die Russen zu zwingen, dort Aufwand zu treiben und sich teuer zu verkaufen
und ihnen da viel abzuverlangen.
Offiziell sagen, was Zelensky dazu gesagt hat, und das fand ich eigentlich ein
ganz brauchbares Statement, wir wollen eine Pufferzone schaffen.
Genau das, was die Russen auch gesagt haben über ihre Rakiv-Offensive.
Genau. Und das macht natürlich insofern Sinn,
weil jetzt natürlich die Kämpfe, wenn die Russen, wie sie üblicherweise so in
der Ukraine vorgegangen sind und alles zu Schutt und Asche schießen, und sagen,
wenigstens jetzt keine ukrainischen Dörfer und ukrainischen Brücken und Straßen
dran glauben müssen und in der Ukraine Flüchtlinge generiert werden,
passiert das halt alles jetzt auf russischer Seite.
Und insofern ist so eine Pufferzone einfach erstmal praktisch,
so kann man sagen. Und ich denke, bei der Frage...
Was ist jetzt irgendwie das Endziel? Also keiner glaubt, dass sie jetzt bis
Moskau durchmarschieren wollen.
Das ist auch eher unrealistisch oder tatsächlich unrealistisch.
Aber ich glaube, dass sehr viel davon abhängt, wie die Russen sich verhalten werden.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, okay, die Ukrainer haben jetzt dieses
oder jenes Ziel und werden das auf Teufel komm raus versuchen zu erreichen.
Sondern ich denke, sie werden auch flexibel reagieren, abhängig davon,
wie Russland jetzt reagiert.
Und was sie halt auch in den ersten Tagen dann genutzt haben, war natürlich,
sie hatten halt auch ausgeguckt, auf welchen Wegen werden die Russen wohl Verstärkung
anbringen und haben dann auch,
wie früher bei entsprechenden Offensiven der Fall war,
dann auch viele Truppen auf dem Anmarsch, wo sie natürlich am meisten verwundbar
sind und wo sie in der Regel konzentriert sind, weil sie dann mit Konvois hingefahren sind,
haben sie teilweise eben komplette anfahrende Konvois beschossen,
weil sie wussten, wo die wohl langfahren werden.
Und das war dann wohl auch unangenehm.
Plus, dass es so aussieht, als wenn die Russen jetzt bisher keine Soldaten von
anderen Frontabschnitten abgezogen hätten.
Sondern nur die Reserven aus anderen Frontabschnitten, aber nicht unbedingt die Fronttruppen.
Das heißt, die Reduktion jetzt,
also die Russen greifen zwar jetzt weniger an, aber nicht in allzu großem Maße
plus, dass sie Grenzen jetzt von der chinesischen Grenze, also ganz vom anderen
Ende jetzt auch abziehen.
Da gab es eine schöne Aufnahme von einem Zug, wo ungefähr eine Bataillonsstärke,
also 20 gepanzerte Kampffahrzeuge,
BMPs, Tanklaster,
ein Bagger...
Unter anderem und ja, ein bisschen Artillerie dann mit dem Zug anrollten,
haben jetzt glaube ich noch 12.000 Kilometer vor sich oder so und bewegten sich dort mit 15 kmh,
weil irgendwie es ein schwer beladener Zug ist,
vier Lokomotiven, zwei vorne, zwei hinten, um das Ding überhaupt zu bewegen
Und jemand meinte, okay, bei dem Tempo brauchen sie wohl drei Monate,
bis sie dann irgendwie das Material an der Front angekommen ist.
Man sollte die Russen jetzt nicht unterschätzen und die haben halt noch,
wie gesagt, an der chinesischen Grenze, aber sie entblößen jetzt immer mehr,
aber versuchen gleichzeitig jetzt den Druck an den anderen Stellen erstmal aufrecht zu erhalten.
Wird man sehen, vollständig scheint ihnen das nicht zu gelingen.
Eben weil, wie erwähnt, das Bahnchaos, weil einerseits dann eben jetzt Strecken weggefallen sind,
aber sie eben andererseits dann auch improvisieren mussten, wo welche Züge jetzt
langfahren, ist ihnen der gesamte Fahrplan durcheinandergeraten.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal harmlos, Fahrplan durcheinandergeraten,
Aber das Problem ist, dass dann eben Loks und Eisen und Waggons und Personal
einfach nicht dort sind,
wo sie sein müssten, damit man Züge bewegen kann.
Das heißt, teilweise stehen Züge jetzt in Bahnhöfen, weil das Personal,
die Lokführer nicht da sind oder...
Die Loks sind einfach an der falschen Stelle oder die Waggons.
Und ja, das halt da wieder Ordnung reinzubringen, ist halt nicht einfach.
Und klar, sie werden es hinkriegen und es rollt sicher auch wieder was.
Aber alleine nur so ein mehrtägiger Ausfall jetzt von Lieferungen,
Verzögerungen ist natürlich auch schon problematisch für Truppen,
die so Ressourcenprobleme haben.
Ja, jetzt ist natürlich viel darüber diskutiert worden, was so die Motivation
der Ukraine war, das überhaupt zu tun.
Ja, ob das so eine gute Idee ist. Je nachdem, wohin man schaut.
Also die deutschen Analysten waren halt sofort so, oh, das könnte das Ende der
Ukraine sein, weil jetzt übernehmen sie sich etc.
Klar, das ist natürlich eine Diskussion.
Kann die Ukraine das jetzt überhaupt militärisch leisten?
Führt das nicht zu einer Überbelastung, wenn sie sowieso schon gerade so viel
verlieren in Donetsk? Aber wie vorhin schon angedeutet, ist das ja auch ein
kalkulierter, schrittweiser Rückzug, den sie dort machen.
In Donetsk läuft das auch gerade darauf hinaus, dass sie die Russen eben so
langsam an eine weitere, besser gesicherte Rückzugslinie heranführen.
Und das eben langsam vorbereiten, aber jetzt auch nicht vorhaben,
dann Prokofsk ohne Kampf aufzugeben oder so etwas.
Weil das ist eine relativ wichtige Stadt, die sie jetzt nicht hergeben wollen.
Warum also dann diese Offensive und was gewinnen sie denn damit?
Rein militärisch ist es erstmal so...
Ukraine macht jetzt überhaupt das erste Mal seit langer Zeit wieder etwas,
wo sie besser sind als die Russen.
Manöverbasiertes Kämpfen ist für so eine besser ausgebildete,
besser ausgestattete, also nicht qualitativ, sondern qualitativ besser ausgestattete
Truppe ein Vorteil gegenüber den Russen.
Und wir haben ja jetzt schon zahlreiche Dinge geschildert, wo die Russen jetzt
überall auf dem linken Fuß erwischt wurden.
Logistisch, die Bahnen, die falschen Truppen an der falschen Stelle,
auch generell einfach im Informationskrieg zurückgelassen worden,
weil sie einfach outsmarted wurden.
Und hier kann die Ukraine Gewinne erzielen und sie erzielt auch Gewinne.
Und sie erzielt Gewinne in signifikanter Größe.
Natürlich stellt sich jetzt die Frage, wie lange können sie das halten,
wie lange wollen sie das halten,
aber das mal erstmal hinten angestellt, ist schon mal ganz interessant zu sehen,
was jetzt die Ukraine mit diesem einen Move für Dilemmata für die Russen geschafft haben.
Und es sind mehrere, die man hier aufzählen könnte.
Es fängt halt an mit diesem militärischen Dilemma.
Dilemma heißt ja immer, es gibt nicht irgendein Problem und da muss man eine
Anstrengung unternehmen und dann ist das Problem weg, sondern ein Dilemma ist die Situation,
in die man seine Gegner immer bringen möchte in diesem Krieg,
so nach dem Motto, okay, das ist jetzt die neue Situation und du hast jetzt
zwei schlechte Möglichkeiten zur Auswahl.
Ja.
Denk mal gut drüber nach, welchen der beiden Nachteile, die du jetzt einfahren möchtest.
Und das ist halt hier auf militärischer Ebene erstmal die Frage, okay,
Behalten wir jetzt unsere Stellung
im Osten oder priorisieren wir die Verteidigung des eigenen Gebiets?
Und das ist ja schon mal nicht einfach, wie wir gesehen haben.
Dann, welche Truppen ziehst du denn dahin? Dadurch, dass sie jetzt nur Wehrpflichtige
und dann diese TikTok-Krieger von diesem schäden Kadirov da,
die Ahmad-Truppen am Start haben,
die immer sehr bekannt dafür sind, dass sie sich, wenn es erstmal Ärger gibt,
dann immer gleich wieder zurückziehen und ihre TikTok-Videos machen und rumhampeln
und aber eigentlich nichts wirklich können.
Ja, also du brauchst halt irgendwie professionelle Truppen und um jetzt überhaupt
erstmal militärische Kompetenz wieder reinzubekommen, müssen sie halt einen
Aufwand treiben, der zwangsläufig die Ressourcen woanders abzieht.
Also selbst wenn sie das jetzt noch nicht getan haben, sie werden da am Ende
nicht drum rum kommen, dass sie also im Zweifelsfall einfach jetzt die Reserven,
die sie sonst vielleicht für einen Austausch der Soldaten an der anderen Front genutzt hätten,
auch wenn sie das ja generell selber selten machen, aber irgendwann sind die
halt auch einfach im Eimer, dass sie die eben woanders hin opfern müssen.
Dann wie schon erwähnt dauern diese Verlagerungen einfach super lange und die
Ukraine bewegt sich ja jetzt auch immer noch super schnell.
Also die haben ihre Battles, wenn die Ukraine irgendwo gewinnt.
In dieser Gegend gibt es keine Minenfelder, in dieser Gegend gibt es keine Trench
Networks, da gibt es keine Gräben, keine Verteidigungsstellen.
Da gibt es auch keine militärische Logistik, die auf diesen Überfall vorbereitet wäre.
Die haben da nicht schon Kommandozentralen eingerichtet, die sie schnell in
Betrieb nehmen können, wie du vorhin gesagt hast, wo sie sich dann schnell mal hin zurückziehen.
Auch das müssen sie alles wieder neu aufbauen.
Und alle Truppen, die sie jetzt schnell heranziehen können, sind halt weniger
kampferfahren und schlecht ausgerüstet sind sie ohnehin.
Dazu kommt, dass sie jetzt auf Druck Versorgungskolonnen bilden müssen,
um überhaupt erstmal genug Ressourcen dahin zu bekommen.
Da muss Munition hingefahren werden, da muss Kampfmaterial, Fahrzeuge hingefahren
werden. Und wir haben schon gesehen, diese ganzen Kolonnen sind leicht zu detektieren
und werden dann halt entsprechend auch sehr effizient bekämpft.
Bei diesem einen Angriff auf diese Versorgungskolonne sollen irgendwie je nach
Quelle 100 bis 400 russische Soldaten auf einmal ums Leben gekommen sein.
Also das ist halt alles ein Problem und wie schon gesagt, sie müssen halt dieses
Atomkraftwerk beschützen, egal was ist und auch ihre Luftverteidigung ist schwierig,
weil die Ukraine halt auch selber mit Luftverteidigungssystemen einmarschiert ist.
Also sie können dort auch nicht so ohne weiteres walten und ihnen ist auch glaube
ich schon einer SO-34 mindestens abgeschlossen worden.
Zwei sogar.
Zwei schon, okay.
Ja. Ja, genau.
Dann gibt es so ein logistisches Dilemma für die Russen, weil sie müssen sich
jetzt hier auch entscheiden, was machen wir denn jetzt mit unseren Einwohnern?
Nicht, dass jetzt Russland dafür bekannt wäre, besonders viel zu geben auf die
eigenen Einwohner, aber die sind natürlich ein Problem.
Einerseits, also eine richtige Evakuierung gab es nicht.
Ja, also davon ist zwar geredet worden, aber die Russen waren logistisch gar
nicht in der Lage oder auch nicht willens, wirklich eine Evakuierung vorzunehmen.
Das heißt, die flüchten jetzt alle auf eigene...
Mit eigenen Maßnahmen.
Mit eigenen Pkw, so nehmen ihre Nachbarn mit.
Genau, das heißt, die haben auch erstmal alle Tankstellen leer gemacht und du
hast dann so 100.000 Leute plus, die da jetzt gerade in der Gegend alle Richtung
Kurs sind, die müssen auch alle irgendwo unterkommen etc.
Das heißt, die Tankstellen sind leer, Tanklaster gibt es nicht viele und das
ist halt irgendwie ein Problem.
Dann kommt der Strom mit dazu, das habe ich vorhin ja gar nicht erwähnt.
In Sucha führt ja auch noch eine der wichtigen Stromleitungen von dem Atomkraftwerk
Kursk, dem NPP Kursk, nach Belgorod.
Das geht da so nach Süden und dann geht das dann halt auch irgendwie nach Belgorod.
Dort ist irgendwie noch nicht gekappt worden, aber ist definitiv ein Problem,
insbesondere weil das andere Atomkraftwerk, was diese Region dann auch mit ausgleichen kann,
was jetzt sozusagen die Netzstabilität betrifft, das ist das in Rostov-on-Don
und da ist geradeaus durch einen Wartungsunfall sowieso alles nur noch auf 50 Prozent Kapazität.
Also da haben sie auf jeden Fall Schiss.
Und dann ist halt einfach der ganze Zugverkehr, das haben wir ja schon gesagt,
so zum Erliegen gekommen.
Züge, Lokomotiven, alles an den falschen Stellen und man hört auch in zunehmendem
Maße, dass eben jetzt auch die russische Eisenbahn Probleme hat mit so Sachen wie Kugellagern.
Das ist ja auf der Sanktionsliste, das kam irgendwie alles aus Deutschland von
deutschen Unternehmen.
Sie haben zwar Produktionsstätten vor Ort, aber du brauchst ja dann auch Teile
und du brauchst dann auch die entsprechende Qualität und die haben sie halt jetzt so nicht mehr.
So, daraus ergibt sich jetzt für Putin auch ein innenpolitisches Dilemma,
weil er sich jetzt irgendwie entscheiden muss,
wie gehen wir denn jetzt personell damit um.
Also jetzt sind da halt die Wehrpflichtigen.
Die Wehrpflichtigen sind ja diejenigen, die eigentlich laut Gesetz in so einem
Krieg im Ausland nicht zum Einsatz kommen dürfen.
Und dementsprechend fühlten die sich wahrscheinlich noch halbwegs sicher,
auch wenn ja auch viele immer Druck ausgeübt wurde und auch jetzt hier in der
Region Kurs gehört man wieder davon.
So nach dem Motto, hier unterschreib mal, sonst hauen wir dir die Birne ein
und dann haben sie doch einen Vertrag und dann werden sie gleich in die Front gefahren.
Aber Wehrpflichtige heißt halt auch immer, da sind jetzt quasi alle Familien
der russischen Föderation mit im Boot.
Auch die in Moskau, auch die in Sankt Petersburg und man kann davon ausgehen,
dass der Anteil von Angehörigen, die jetzt eben in diesen kernrussischen Gebieten
leben, die ja bisher weitgehend von diesem Krieg ausgenommen waren,
jetzt durchaus da auch mal so ihre Wehrpflichtigen haben und einige davon unter
Umständen auch schon gefangen genommen worden oder auch getötet worden sind.
Das bedeutet, dass sich jetzt halt Putin auch entscheiden muss,
okay, wie gehen wir denn damit um?
Weil es war ja immer das Argument, naja, das ist ja kein Krieg,
das ist ja eine spezielle militärische Operation, die SMO, weil es ist ja kein Krieg.
Weil wenn es Krieg wäre, dann müssten wir eine Generalmobilmachung ausrufen
und die hat er ja bisher immer vermieden.
Jetzt ist aber Russland angegriffen worden auf dem eigenen Gebiet und da sind
dann die Wehrpflichtigen im Prinzip auch mit drin.
Und das schafft für ihn natürlich eine politische, eine innenpolitische Situation,
die er halt eigentlich jetzt seit Beginn dieses Kriegs immer versucht hat zu vermeiden.
Muss aber jetzt in irgendeiner Form Truppen aufstellen, weil sonst wird ja noch
mehr Gebiet besetzt und Krieg kann man nun nicht ausrufen.
Also müssen sie jetzt mit ihrer Schattenmobilisierung weitermachen.
Aber dass sie halt auch keinen Krieg ausrufen, steht dann natürlich auch doof
da, weil man sich natürlich dann fragt.
Was muss denn jetzt noch passieren, bis Russland auch mal im Krieg ist?
Müssen die Truppen da schon vor Moskau oder vor St. Petersburg stehen und dann
so, ja jetzt können wir langsam mal Krieg feststellen?
Also das ist so eine Debatte, die sozusagen auch nicht da ist.
Jetzt werden sie also weiterhin versuchen, irgendwelche Unwilligen,
die sie eh kaserniert haben, dahin zu fahren etc.
Aber ob das ausreichen wird, jetzt diese hochmotivierten und gut ausgerüsteten
und schnell voranstoßenden Ukrainer auch nur irgendwie nennenswert in den Griff
zu bekommen, da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Mittlerweile schalten sie auf russischem Ebay, das heißt irgendwie anders,
ich habe vergessen wie der Name ist, nach Leuten, die Gräben ausheben in Kurs.
Sowas läuft da jetzt gerade Plus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast Bilder aus dem russischen Fernsehen das
sich bisher vor allem auf die Hilfsmaßnahmen,
konzentriert und wo sie dann mitten in Kursk auf dem Platz so Zeltlager aufgebaut
haben so mit 100 Betten für so 100 Flüchtlinge,
wo ich dann dachte also erstens haben die keine Turnhallen oder Schulen oder
wo sie die Leute einfach unterbringen können und vor allen Dingen ich meine 100,
Und 100 Schlafplätze in Zelten, kann man sagen, okay, das ist nur sozusagen
vielleicht so ein Zwischenlager, wo die Leute dann vielleicht eine Nacht verbringen können.
Aber selbst das fand ich halt schon so ein bisschen absurd.
Und generell, und dann noch scheinen die Russen jetzt, scheint die russische
Propaganda es mehr als Naturkatastrophe zu sehen.
Sozusagen nicht irgendwie ein Akt tatsächlich von Krieg, sondern es ist halt
wie, ja, keine Ahnung, schlechtes Wetter, Überschwemmung.
Ja, es passiert halt von Zeit zu Zeit.
Ja, ab und zu schwappen da mal irgendwelche Leute über die Grenze,
so kann schon mal passieren mit Waffen und so.
Ja, aber gerade die russische Propaganda, die dreht sich natürlich gerade richtig
im Kreis, weil jetzt eigentlich genau das passiert, was Sie immer gesagt haben,
was gar nicht passieren kann.
Jetzt passiert es aber trotzdem und vor allem am Anfang der Offensive haben
sie ja dann auch die ganze Zeit so, ja nichts ist passiert,
es gibt nichts zu sehen, was dann auch dazu geführt hat, dass die Bevölkerung
gedacht hat, so ja dann ist ja auch nichts und auf einmal stehen die Ukrainer im Hof so.
Also das kam dann irgendwie auch nicht so richtig gut an.
Ja und wenn man sich das Propaganda-Fernsehen mittlerweile anschaut,
also ich habe mir so ein paar Sendungen jetzt der letzten Tage übersetzt mal
angeschaut, die drehen sich schon im Kreis.
Also die sagen schon so, ja es wird zu viel gelogen und jetzt irgendwie haben
wir ja wirklich mal ein richtiges Problem.
Also das ist so eine Situation, die kriegen sie jetzt gar nicht mehr wegdiskutiert,
weil zwangsläufig sie allem widersprechen müssen, was sie bisher behauptet haben
und was auch sehr interessant ist, was sie nicht sagen.
Sie sagen nicht, jetzt müssen wir da mal hier Berlin mit Atomraketen klein machen. Genau.
Selten so wenig Atomdrohungen gehört wie in der letzten Woche aus Russland.
Weil das passt ja nicht.
Wenn es irgendwie eine Naturkatastrophe ist und es eigentlich nichts zu sehen
gibt, gibt es auch keinen Grund da jetzt... Aber der eigentliche Grund ist, weil Sie wissen...
Dass sie das sowieso nicht wahrmachen können.
Gar nicht auf eigenem Gebiet.
Ja gut, da gab es halt schon auch Überlegungen früher, ob Russland nicht auf
eigenem Gebiet eine Atomwaffe zünden sollte und so.
Aber im Moment sind sie da gerade ganz weit weg von. Also genau auf dem entgegengesetzten Trip.
Und ja,
also das ist mir auch aufgefallen, so dass plötzlich ja die Russen, also plus.
Sie versuchen es unbedingt zu vermeiden, konkrete Zahlen zu nennen.
Also sie vermeiden es, über die Zahl der besetzten Ortschaften im russischen Fernsehen zu reden.
Also wenn da jemand versucht, das auszusprechen, wird das sofort,
so bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahme, die Propagandisten, Interviewpartner oder wie
viele Leute auf der Flucht sind oder wie viele Quadratkilometer.
Da bloß nichts Konkretes äußern dazu im Moment.
Und auch Putin hat dann den Bezirksgouverneur da oder Bürgermeister von Kursk
oder wer das auch immer war,
der dann ansetzen wollte in der Berichterstattung meinte,
von Ihnen will ich nur was über die Hilfsmaßnahmen hören, die angelaufen sind,
die militärische Situation, da haben wir andere Experten.
Und trotzdem sind das genau die Ränke, die als erstes geopfert werden,
wenn die Leute sich beschweren. Dann sind es halt immer die Gouverneure,
die die Fehler gemacht haben.
Niemals ist es der Herrscher selbst.
Ja, ja, Putin, also wenn, dann sind das sowieso andere Schuld.
Und natürlich hat man wieder gesehen viele Hilfsappelle, natürlich an Putin,
der doch jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, für Hilfe sorgen soll, das ist das Übliche.
Und wenn ich dann so ja und wir haben ja irgendwie den Krieg gegen die Ukraine
die ganze Zeit tapfer unterstützt und so und jetzt werden wir hier im,
wir sind gute Russen und jetzt werden wir hier plötzlich so im Regen stehen gelassen.
Und naja.
Auch wenn es natürlich menschlich tragisch ist für die Leute und es da sicherlich
auch, wie immer, viele Leute in der Zivilbevölkerung gibt,
wo man sagen kann, okay, irgendwelche 80-Jährigen, die da leben,
die nun überhaupt nichts so richtig damit am Hut haben.
Aber trotzdem hatte man das Gefühl, und ich glaube, das ging fast allen so,
als man dann die Russen gesehen hat plötzlich als Flüchtlinge und Besatzung.
Und man sagt, okay, das ist halt eigentlich, ja, das ist halt wahrscheinlich Karma, so at work.
Und dass das schon irgendwie ausgleichende Gerechtigkeit ist,
dass jetzt auch die russische Bevölkerung zu spüren bekommt.
Was selbst in sehr abgemilderter Form, aber nichtsdestotrotz aus deinem Heim
und Zuhause vertrieben zu werden, was dann vielleicht auch zerstört wird.
Unter anderem, das ist schon hart, selbst wenn du jetzt flüchtest und nicht
gefangen und in einem Keller gefoltert wirst oder so, wie das dann die Russen
teilweise gemacht haben.
Und ja, also ich muss sagen, so eine gewisse Schadenfreude konnte ich mir dort
einfach nicht versagen, als ich dann dort die Russen gesehen habe.
Und der Grund dafür, man kann ja auch sagen, wieso reagieren die Russen so seltsam?
Und in der Ukraine,
als die Russen einmarschiert sind in den ersten zwei Wochen jetzt vor zwei Jahren,
da haben sich ja überall dann auch Territorialverteidigungsgruppen gebildet.
Die Leute haben mit Jagdgewehren Jagd auf russische Soldaten gemacht und, und, und.
Während, ja, jetzt die Russen, auch die Bevölkerung, die sich in erster Linie
zurückgezogen haben. Die meisten sind halt einfach weg.
Und die anderen sind einfach geblieben, aber tun halt auch nichts.
Und die Frage ist jetzt so, warum?
Was geht da eigentlich vor in den Russen?
Und das ist so eine wirklich ganz merkwürdige Mischung von dem,
was ich gehört habe jetzt von verschiedenen Russen, die da auf YouTube jetzt
kommentiert haben, was sie glauben,
was in der Bevölkerung vorgeht.
Das eine ist, dass die Russen, die in der Gegend leben,
die Ukrainer gar nicht so als Feinde empfinden oder als feindliche Macht unbedingt.
Jedenfalls nicht wesentlich anders, als sie jetzt die Kolonialmacht Moskau dort empfinden.
Also es ist sozusagen eigentlich nur ein Besatzer gegen den anderen ausgetauscht, so ungefähr.
Die zweite Sache ist, dass viele Leute sich ja, also die Hälfte der Russen ungefähr,
mindestens sich politisch komplett verabschiedet hat von Politik.
Also sie interessiert Politik eigentlich null.
Die wollen es einfach nicht wissen.
Beziehungsweise es ist ihnen so eindoktriniert worden, dass sie sich da rauszuhalten haben.
Du hältst dich aus dem Staat raus und der Staat hält sich bei dir raus. Das ist der Deal.
Ja, aber jetzt, wo auch noch schlechte Nachrichten kommen oder richtig schlechte
Nachrichten auf einmal,
hat das das Interesse dieser Leute nicht unbedingt erhöht,
sich damit zu beschäftigen, sondern die haben dann eher die Scheuklappen noch
ein bisschen tiefer gezogen und wollen eigentlich überhaupt nichts davon wissen
und sehen das Ganze einfach als Problem anderer Leute.
Ja, die sich darum zu kümmern haben.
Also sie wollen da einfach nicht involviert sein, das sollen die da oben mal
schön bitte regeln und klären und ich habe damit nichts zu tun.
Das ist so ein bisschen, scheint in vielen Köpfen dort vorzuherrschen.
Was auch noch sehr interessant ist, in solchen Situationen, man hat das jetzt
gesehen bei allen kriegsbezogenen und auch nicht kriegsbezogenen Katastrophen,
die so in den letzten zwei Jahren passiert sind.
Also auch jetzt diese ganzen Überflutungen und im Winter, als die ganze Zeit
die Heizungen explodiert sind etc.
Permanent Stromausfälle. Also es gibt ja in vielen Regionen der russischen Föderation
viele beklagenswerte Vorgänge.
Und dann natürlich auch die ganzen Mütter von irgendwelchen Soldaten,
die dann schlecht behandelt wurden und sich irgendwie gemeldet haben mit,
ich werde hier gefoltert, ich werde hier geschlagen,
ich werde hier in den Tod geschickt und mein Vertrag ist ja eigentlich abgelaufen
und ich werde trotzdem noch an die Front geschickt.
All diese ganzen Sachen, wo wir halt schon als Beobachter die ganze Zeit denken
so, ja Leute, that's how it works irgendwie, das ist das, was da passiert,
warum merkt ihr denn das nicht?
Die merken es halt nicht, weil sie einfach mental und medial komplett abgeschirmt
werden von diesen ganzen Realitäten.
Und dann, wenn sie dann aber doch feststellen, die Kacke ist am Dampfen,
mich betrifft das jetzt auch,
dann nehmen sie diese creepy Videos auf, wo sie sich dann alle als Menschengruppe
vor die Kamera stellen und wen bitten sie dann ausgerechnet um Hilfe? Putin.
Das ist dann immer so, ja hier, Wladimir, wie heißt dein zweiter Vorname,
Wladimirovic, weiß ich nicht,
ja wir sind hier deine Bürger, übrigens, wirst dich sicherlich noch an uns erinnern,
wir haben da ein Problem, kannst du uns bitte helfen?
Und das ist so ein bisschen so wie bei Hallo Spencer, wir rufen dich Galaktika
vom fernen Stern Andromeda, du musst uns jetzt hier irgendwie helfen,
wir kommen jetzt nicht mehr klar.
Weil dieser Glaube in dieser russischen Gesellschaft nach wie vor so ist,
dass Putin ja eigentlich alles ganz toll regelt und irgendwie der Superzar ist,
der irgendwie nur das Beste will für das Land.
Aber leider diese ganzen lokalen Gouverneure oder sonstigen Bezirksvorsteher,
von denen sie ja auch wissen, dass die alle durch und durch korrupt sind und
nur die kennen sie ja wirklich persönlich, dass die das alles verkackt haben.
Und die Information bloß noch nicht bis zu Putin vorgedrungen ist.
Also die Vorstellung, dass all diese Informationen innerhalb von Mikrosekunden
bei Putin ohnehin vorliegen, haben die gar nicht.
Sondern für die ist die Welt noch groß und langsam und Dinge passieren lokal
und was irgendwo in anderen Gebieten Russlands passiert,
tangiert die genauso wenig wie uns Dinge tangieren, die, was weiß ich,
in Papua Neuguinea passieren.
Und dann bricht aber auf einmal das Unglück über sie herein und die einzige
Stelle, die sie irgendwie formulieren können, wo sie glauben,
dass sie dann selbstverständlicher Hilfe bekommen müssen, das ist dann irgendwie Putin.
Aber diese Vorstellung, dass das ganze System vom Kopf her stinkt,
die ist einfach überhaupt nicht präsent in dieser Gesellschaft.
Also es ist wirklich eine ganze Menge im Arsch in Russland. Das macht einen
fassungslos, wenn man sich das irgendwie anschaut.
Ja, ich habe noch ein weiteres Dilemma, was jetzt sozusagen ausgelöst wurde
für die Russen oder beziehungsweise in dem Fall ist es vielleicht mal wirklich ein Problem,
weil da haben die Russen jetzt eigentlich nichts zu entscheiden und das ist
die außenpolitische Wirkung dieser Maßnahme.
Denn es macht ja nun wirklich den Eindruck, dass auch die Amerikaner und alle
westlichen Verbündeten und die Deutschen sowieso nicht,
nicht eingebunden waren in die Planung oder auch nur benachrichtigt wurden oder
auch nicht zehn Minuten vorher nochmal Bescheid gesagt haben.
Also das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Zehn Minuten vorher haben sie vielleicht, vielleicht haben sie zehn Minuten
vorher Bescheid gesagt, aber definitiv nicht eine Woche vorher und schon gar
nicht waren die USA in irgendeiner Form involviert und damit halt auch die NATO
und sonst niemand nicht.
Die sind da einfach einmarschiert aus all diesen ganzen Überlegungen,
die wir jetzt schon vorher gemacht haben, welche Probleme sie den Russen damit
schaffen, welche Vorteile sie sich selber damit verschaffen.
Und auf einmal wurden die Mikrofone in die Gesichter der Entscheider und des
Präsidenten gehalten und dann so,
ja hier die Ukraine marschiert mit britischen Panzern und deutschen Schützenpanzern
und amerikanischen Waffen gerade in Russland ein. Herr Präsident, was sagen Sie dazu?
Und der Präsident so, ja, passt schon.
Also das war so im Wesentlichen die Reaktion des Westens, war so,
ja ne, wussten wir jetzt nichts von, aber das ist schon irgendwie so.
Mit anderen Worten, die Ukraine hat es geschafft, den Westen vollvollendete
Tatsachen zu stellen und sie hätten sich jetzt im Prinzip ja eigentlich nur
entscheiden können zwischen,
wir verurteilen das und das ging nicht oder ja, nee,
ist schon richtig so irgendwie.
Weil jetzt zuzugeben, dass sie eigentlich dazu Nein gesagt hätten,
aber nicht Nein sagen konnten.
Das ging halt gar nicht. Und das ist natürlich jetzt echt ein Move,
weil nachdem jetzt schon, wie vorhin erwähnt, bei dieser Krakiv-Offensive die
amerikanische Politik dahingehend geändert werden musste,
dass sie also dann trotzdem mit Heimars in Russland schon mal angreifen durften,
geht es natürlich jetzt einen Schritt weiter.
Und die Debatte ist natürlich jetzt ganz heiß um, können wir dort Attackams
einsetzen oder nicht, weil das fehlt den Ukrainern.
Die hätten schon so viele Flugzeuge zerstören können auf diesen Flughäfen,
wenn sie die hätten benutzen dürfen und derzeit gibt es immer noch genug Widerstand
von Joe Biden, der das irgendwie nicht erlaubt.
Aber auch Deutschland, also Leopards habe ich jetzt noch keine gesehen,
aber so Marder sind da definitiv unterwegs und wahrscheinlich auch die ein oder
andere Panzerhaubitze 2000.
Kommentar aus allen Richtungen war immer nur so, naja das gehört ja jetzt der Ukraine.
Genau, das sind jetzt ukrainische Waffen.
Was haben wir damit zu tun? Aber es haben wir für eine monatelange Diskussion
geführt, so, ja, das deutsche Panzer in Russland und so weiter,
die Bilder aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, das wollen wir nicht wieder haben und so.
Und mit anderen Worten, durch diese ganze Maßnahme gibt es jetzt eine Akzeptanz
dieser Maßnahme, de facto, weil sich keiner so richtig dagegen.
Keiner sich richtig dich dagegen einstellen kann.
So, und jetzt gibt es aber wieder ein Problem für die Russen,
weil in dieser ganzen Debatte um,
wie einigen wir uns in möglichen Friedensgesprächen und dann hast du ja hier so die,
Wagenknechte und sonstigen Putin-Versteher in Deutschland auch und weltweit,
gibt es die natürlich überall, die ja immer sagen so ja, dieser Konflikt muss eingefroren werden,
Waffenstillstand jetzt, wir wollen ja Frieden Und wenn keine Waffen fliegen,
dann ist ja automatisch Frieden und so.
Und damit natürlich immer wieder gesagt haben, die Ukraine muss akzeptieren,
dass die Russen ihnen Gebiet wegnehmen, dreht sich der Spieß jetzt um.
Weil ein Einfrieren des Konfliktes natürlich auch bedeuten würde,
ja okay, dann gehört also Sucha.
Ab sofort jetzt zur Ukraine oder was?
Und dadurch ändert sich natürlich auch die Gesamtmengel-Lage.
Also ich würde jetzt noch nicht sagen, dass diese 500,
Entschuldigung, diese 1100 Quadratkilometer, die da jetzt besetzt worden sind,
wenn man sich das jetzt mal im Vergleich zu der Gesamtregion Russland anschaut,
ist das ja nach wie vor ein Klacks.
Ja, so Berlin und Potsdam, das kannst du da tausendmal rausstempeln aus dem russischen Gebiet.
Aber darum geht es ja nicht. Es geht darum, dass generell diese Vorstellung,
dass auch die Ukraine genauso gut den Russen was wegnehmen kann,
wie die Russen der Ukraine die ganze Zeit was wegnehmen,
das muss Moskau einfach schmerzen.
Ja, ja. Und weil du, ich sag mal, schon unsere Wagenknechte und Co.
Erwähnt hast, meine These ist,
dass diese Leute, eigentlich in erster Linie auch Biden und vor allem Trump
und so, eigentlich dafür verantwortlich sind, dass es jetzt zu dieser Eskalation gekommen ist.
Und es war eine gefährliche Eskalation.
Es war ein Gamble definitiv. Erst mal Risiko für die eigenen Truppen, aber auch das Risiko,
eine Überreaktion von Russland zu provozieren.
Und ich glaube, dass die Ukraine lieber, wenn die...
Dafür ausgestattet, vernünftig ausgestattet worden wäre, lieber ukrainisches
Territorium befreit hätte, als jetzt nach Russland reinzugehen.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass aber durch die mangelhafte Unterstützung ihnen das
verwehrt wurde, ist es jetzt zu dieser Eskalation gekommen.
Und das ist meine These seit langem, dass es viel gefährlicher ist,
die Ukraine in die Enge zu treiben und dass das zu einer Eskalation führt,
mehr noch, wie wir sehen, als wenn man jetzt Russland in die Enge treibt.
Oder ich meine, von Inni Engel treiben kann ja nicht wirklich die Rede sein.
Und wenn man das jetzt extrapoliert und jetzt sagt, okay, was ist jetzt gefährlicher?
Also jetzt so hypothetisch, wenn jetzt der Westen, der Ukraine,
wie es ja viele dieser Leute fordern, jetzt einfach die Unterstützung entzieht
und dass dann der Krieg zu Ende ist,
das halte ich für eher unwahrscheinlich.
Sondern so die Ukraine hat noch jede Menge Eskalationsmöglichkeiten und ganz am Ende steht,
was sich viele auch nicht, worüber sich auch viele nicht im Klaren sind,
ist, dass es Ukrainer waren,
die den Großteil der russischen Atomwaffen mitentwickelt und aufgebaut haben.
Und die Ukrainer haben ja Kernkraftwerke am Laufen und haben genug spaltbares
Material und Plutonium, da brauchst du noch nicht mal Zentrifugen.
Das alles steht bisher immer noch unter Aufsicht der internationalen Atombehörde und so.
Und die haben da überall Kameras und deswegen gibt es, es gibt jetzt keinerlei
Anzeichen dafür, dass die Ukrainer irgendwas in dieser Richtung auch noch planen würden.
Aber wenn es hart auf hart kommt, so, dann traue ich den Ukrainern zu,
zum Beispiel eine Atomwaffe nach Moskau reinzuschmuggeln und die dort detonieren zu lassen.
So, also in anderen Worten, man sollte nicht glauben,
dass jetzt die Ukrainer, wenn sie wirklich in die Enge getrieben werden und
es wirklich existenziell wird,
also bisher hält man die Ukraine mit hinreichend Waffen auf.
Sagen, davon ab, komplett besiegt zu werden.
Aber es ist auch jetzt klar geworden, dass der Westen bislang immer noch davor
zurückschreckt, die Ukraine mit dem auszustatten, was sie braucht, um zu gewinnen.
So, ja, sind immer noch in dieser Situation.
Und jetzt dieser Vorstoß könnte jetzt vielleicht auch ein Stück weit dazu beitragen,
dass sich das eben lockert.
Man nimmt jetzt nicht an, dass jetzt gleich drei Tage oder zehn Tage nach dem
Einmarsch jetzt öffentlich der Westen verkündet und jetzt heben wir die Beschränkungen
auf oder was. Das wäre halt ein bisschen unglückliches Timing.
Aber eigentlich gehen alle davon aus,
dass eine weitere rote Linie der Russen sich einfach als Luftnummer erwiesen
hat oder eine angenommene rote Linie.
Aber vor zwei Jahren irgendwann haben wir das Thema Atom und Atomdoktrin mal behandelt.
Und da ist es so,
die offizielle russische Atomdoktrin
ist wesentlich restriktiver als beispielsweise die der Amerikaner.
Aber die sagt halt nur tatsächlich, also Atomwaffeneinsatz, wenn entweder die
Atomwaffen oder Trägersysteme in Gefahr ist oder Truppen vor Moskau stehen.
Ja, so, also jetzt nicht, wenn signifikante Teile eben, also wenn die Existenz
Russlands tatsächlich bedroht ist.
Und davon ist man hier jetzt weit, weit entfernt. und insofern nur mein Punkt, dass.
Ja, Dinge eskalieren können, wenn man vermeintlich deeskalieren möchte,
weil einfach das so nicht funktioniert.
Die Realität funktioniert so nicht. Und eine andere Sache noch generell,
was auch von vielen Analysten, auch teilweise ukrainischen Analysten gesagt wurde.
Die haben halt in den letzten Monaten auch die Führung stark kritisiert für
diese lineare Verteidigung.
Ja, und die halt meinten, man müsse unbedingt wieder zu einem Bewegungskrieg
übergehen und einfach Risiken eingehen, weil Leute sterben so oder so im Krieg.
Das ist nun mal unvermeidlich. Und das Problem ist nur,
dass im Westen man einfach extrem risikoscheu geworden ist,
was so militärische Aktionen angeht, weil jeder einzelne Gefallene dort ist ein Problem im Westen.
Weswegen man sich das auch nicht vorstellen konnte,
aber dass die Ukraine jetzt mal wieder gezeigt hat, dass diese Denke,
bloß nichts riskieren, bloß auf Nummer sicher gehen,
dass man damit so einen Konflikt oder Krieg nicht gewinnt.
Sondern dass man einfach Risiken eingehen muss, um was zu erreichen.
Und dieses Denken ist in westlichen Köpfen einfach nicht da gewesen.
Und ja, und es sind natürlich einige Leute, die das schon seit Monaten gesagt
haben, sind natürlich jetzt sehr froh, dass die Ukraine jetzt gesagt hat, okay, liebe NATO,
liebe Amerikaner, liebe wer auch immer, was ihr uns hier erzählt,
was wir machen sollen, funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes oder das Gegenteil von dem,
was ihr uns versucht, hier die ganze Zeit einzureden.
Und das hat glaube ich auch ein gewisses Stück Wahrheit einfach, dass,
Das zeigt, wie man erfolgreich sein kann,
auch gegen einen überlegenen Gegner, nämlich durch Initiative und durch das
Eingehen kalkulierter Risiken und durch gute Planung.
Ja, und sofern kann man sagen, mal wieder Hut ab vor den Ukrainern,
dass die in der Lage waren, das durchzuziehen.
Absolut. Also das ist glaube ich wirklich die Lehre, die man jetzt hier rausziehen muss.
Umso befremdlicher, dass halt dann gleich auch wieder die Angst regiert.
Also insbesondere die Kommentatoren aus Deutschland sehen einfach diesen Pfad
irgendwie überhaupt nicht.
Und man kann jetzt nur hoffen, dass durch die neue Konstellation in den USA
sich hier das Blatt dann auch entsprechend wendet.
Derzeit scheint die Beratungsresistenz von Joe Biden noch anzuhalten,
aber mittlerweile, wie wir ja alle mitbekommen haben, dürfte das Joe Biden aus
dem Präsidentschaftsrennen ausgeschieden.
Und das neue demokratische Ticket mit Kamala Harris und Tim Walz scheint da
einen ganz anderen Ansatz zu haben.
Bei Kamala Harris bin ich mir jetzt selber ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ganz so
sicher, aber die wird sicherlich nicht mehr die Perspektive des Kalten Krieges
haben, sondern eher die 90er vor Augen zu haben mit dem Niedergang Russlands
bei ihrer Entscheidung.
Und Tim Woltz selber ist ein offener.
Unterstützer der Ukraine ohnehin. Wenn es also nun endlich gelingt,
Donald Trump mal aufs Abstellgleis zu stellen und danach alle Verbindungen dahin
zu kappen und die Wahl entsprechend ausgeht, denke ich mal,
ist der politische Raum für einen Neuanfang in dieser Hinsicht auf jeden Fall geschaffen.
Aber Europa müsste sich ja auch bewegen.
Aber ja, ich fürchte, dass der Wahlkampf in den USA nicht unbedingt hilfreich
ist im Moment für die Ukraine und dass eigentlich eher keine,
ich sag mal, ich keine spektakulären Entscheidungen jetzt noch von beiden erwarte,
weil es herrscht so ein bisschen einmal die Vorstellung vor, okay,
es läuft im Moment gut für die Demokraten, auch wenn es ungewöhnlich knapp ist nach wie vor.
Und dass erstens das wahrscheinlich gewinnen wird, wer es vermeiden wird,
schwerwiegende Fehler zu machen in den nächsten Monaten.
So, sodass man jetzt versucht, ja, einfach auch größere Fehler zu vermeiden.
Aber gut, wer weiß.
Am Ende...
Es sind Überraschungen möglich, aber auf jeden Fall sehe ich jetzt in den nächsten
Monaten bis November jetzt keine wesentlichen Veränderungen in der Position,
was die Ukraine angeht, sondern man wird mehr oder weniger Kurs halten.
Das ist das, was ich erwarte in den USA.
Und ja, insgesamt ist das, was in den USA passiert, mittelfristig erfreulich
und hat Potenzial, wie du sagst.
Wenn tatsächlich es gelingt, nicht nur die Wahl zu gewinnen,
sondern tatsächlich auch, worauf ich hoffe, ist,
dass dieser ganze MAGA-Unflug einfach beerdigt wird.
Dass sie sich eine Klatsche einfangen und dass auch Senat und Repräsentantenhaus,
die ja dann auch wieder halb oder zum Teil neu besetzt werden,
dass auch dort die Demokraten eine Mehrheit bekommen und dann in der Lage sind,
einfach mal ein bisschen durchzuregieren.
Auf jeden fall und das ist zumindest jetzt wieder in den bereich des des möglichen gekommen.
Und gut, am Ende bei Trump, was passiert, wenn Trump gewinnt,
jetzt im Hinblick auf die Ukraine, kann wahrscheinlich kein Mensch sagen,
weil Trump ist halt einen Tag so, einen Tag so und äußert sich dann auch mal positiv über Zelensky.
Und ich meine, wenn du dir überlegst, wen er zum Vizepräsidenten gemacht hat
und wie dieser Waltz noch vor zwei Jahren über Donald Trump geredet hat,
ihn mit Hitler verglichen hat und ihm...
Du meinst Vance. Er hat ihn nicht zum Vizepräsidenten gemacht.
Sondern zum Kandidaten. Vizepräsident, Kandidaten, ja. Okay, ja.
Vance Waltz, ich weiß, aber das ist jetzt der Vance.
Jaja, also genau. Also wen er da zum Vizepräsidenten machen möchte und wen er
sich da ausgesucht hat, zeigt für mich halt vor allem,
dass er komplett wankelmütig ist.
Was interessiert mich mein Geschwätz von gestern?
Und keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich, wenn Selenskyj vorbeikommt mit einem netten
Kuchen oder so und ein bisschen den Diktator raushängen lässt,
so nach dem Motto, ich habe jetzt ja auch irgendwie mal die Wahlen jetzt verschoben und so.
Schließe ich es nicht aus, dass die beiden plötzlich größte Freunde werden.
Aber das ist halt die Gefahr. Man weiß es einfach nicht bei Trump.
Und vielleicht noch ein Ding dazu, was da reinspielt.
Trump kümmert sich ein Dreck darum, was Republikaner oder republikanische Positionen oder Werte sind.
Das interessiert ihn nicht. Und ich habe ein interessantes Interview mit jemandem gehört,
der auch mal ihn unterstützt hat und damals im siegreichen Wahlkampf.
Also als Trump erstmalig kandidiert hat und dann angefangen hat,
da aufzutreten und was er dann erzählt hat,
so haben ihn alle Republikaner erstmal...
Die da länger schon drin waren, man guckt, aber das war jetzt überhaupt gar
kein republikanischer Speech, den er da gehalten hat.
Das sind doch überhaupt nicht unsere Positionen.
Und Trump so, ja, interessiert mich aber nicht.
Mich interessiert, was irgendwie bei den Leuten ankommt, gut ankommt und nicht was so.
Und deswegen, man sieht das, er hat mehr oder weniger, also er ist unchecked,
er hat sämtliche, kann eigentlich machen, was er will dort.
Und wie gesagt, mit Trump ist alles möglich.
Einschließlich, dass er sich überlegt, dann schicke ich jetzt amerikanische Truppen.
Selbst das würde ich nicht ausschließen, wenn Putin irgendwas sagt, was ihn erregt oder so.
Deswegen lieber nicht Trump, weil mit Trump aus meiner Sicht steigt auch die
Gefahr eines Atomkriegs ganz klar,
wenn der am Ruder ist, weil der Typ ist einfach durch, der ist durchgeknallt.
Ja, das kann man feststellen und interessanterweise wird das ja jetzt auch in
dem Wahlkampf vermehrt festgestellt und auch zum Slogan an sich,
seitdem Tim Waltz die ganze Truppe weird genannt hat, dreht sich auf einmal
das Blatt, was ich ganz interessant finde.
Manchmal ist es dann doch ganz gut, die einfach nur lächerlich zu finden und
nicht die ganze Zeit das Schlimmste, was uns passieren kann,
an die Wand zu malen, weil das interessiert die Leute irgendwie nicht.
Aber wenn Leute irgendwie komisch sind, das ist dann halt irgendwie schon ein echtes Problem.
Okay, ähm...
Vielleicht damit den außenpolitischen Ausritt abschließen, würde ich sagen.
Möchtest du noch was zur Situation in Russland an sich sagen,
bevor wir dann nochmal auf Militärtechnik zu sprechen kommen?
Genau, das meiste hatten wir ja schon gesagt. Aber wirtschaftlich sieht es auch
nicht gut aus für Russland.
Man hat jetzt Preiskontrollen ausgeweitet.
Die größten Retailer dürfen jetzt ihre Preise nicht mehr erhöhen.
Es ist ungefähr so, wenn es Amazon oder wer auch immer auf Amazon verkauft,
verboten wird, irgendwie die Preise zu erhöhen.
Nur wenn der ganze Kram aus dem Ausland kommt, ist das natürlich auch keine
nachhaltige Lösung. Aber definitiv hat man das Gefühl, dass Putin ins Schwimmen gekommen ist.
Allein nur die Gesichter, die man gesehen hat von ihm und den ganzen,
also die guckten alle not amused.
Und dann hat er irgendwie Armeegeneral Gerasimov irgendwie so halb entmachtet,
nämlich ihm die Zuständigkeit für die Bekämpfung der Kursoffensive abgenommen
und stattdessen an FSB-Geheimdienstchef Bortnikow gegeben.
Geben, so nach dem Motto, das ist ja nur eine Anti-Terror-Operation,
das heißt, es hat ja mit Krieg nichts zu tun, was hier passiert und äh.
Außerdem, was man irgendwie gut sehen konnte,
fand ich, vielleicht interpretiere ich da zu viel rein, aber es gab halt auch
eine Übertragung, wo Putin und Gerasimov und Botnikow da saßen.
Und Gerasimov so mit gesenktem Kopf und irgendwie schwafelte dann irgendwas
und Botnikov guckte ihn die ganze Zeit wirklich an mit einem Gesicht.
So nach dem Motto, was für einen Scheiß erzählst du hier gerade eigentlich so,
als der meinte, ja und die Situation ist im Griff und wir werden die irgendwie
zurückschicken Und sowohl Putin als auch Botnikow waren wahrscheinlich halbwegs,
also so gut informiert,
wie man nur informiert sein kann,
jedenfalls gut genug informiert, um zu sehen, dass ihnen Gerasimov gerade jetzt
entweder einen Bären auftischt oder wirklich keine Ahnung hat, was vor sich geht.
Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auch eine Rolle spielte.
Aber das Problem, was jetzt dadurch entsteht, ist, dass Putin ja eine wichtige Machtbasis ist,
so diese Vertikale, die er da errichtet hat, indem er aber die drei wichtigsten Geheimdienst,
FSB.
Die Armee und dann die Polizeitruppen und die Truppen des Innenministeriums.
Jeweils drei Machtfaktoren, wo er dann den Schiedsrichter spielen kann, die dann immer im...
Und sozusagen die Checks and
Balances in Russland sind halt drei Sicherheitsdienste nur mittlerweile.
Mittlerweile, ja, die Truppen des Innenministeriums oder so,
die sind so ein bisschen schon seit langem abgemeldet und jetzt scheint es so
zu sein, dass halt klar ist,
dass jetzt der FSB einfach die Macht ist,
auf die sich Putin jetzt stützt.
Was ihnen aber eben langfristig oder mittelfristig einfach Probleme bereiten
kann, weil wenn sich jetzt irgendjemand im FSB überlegt,
so, wir haben da jetzt keinen Bock mehr drauf,
dann wird Putin sich auf Armee und Innenministeriumstruppen nicht mehr verlassen können.
So, die werden ihm dann nicht zur Hilfe eilen.
Das heißt, er hat jetzt quasi durch seine Entscheidungen auch zusätzlich die
Stabilität seiner Herrschaft verringert.
Das könnte also auch langfristige Folgen jetzt haben. Aber im Moment,
wie gesagt, spielt das alles runter und sieht nicht so aus.
Und es sind halt nach wie vor andere, die schuld sind.
Es hat nichts mit ihm zu tun, sondern ja, dieser ganze Konflikt.
Also es ist wirklich immer schwierig einzuschätzen, welchen Grad an Stabilität
dieses Regime eigentlich noch hat.
Aber ich glaube, wir hatten hier schon immer so ein bisschen diese Perspektive
aufgemacht. Wenn es irgendwann fällt, geht es sehr schnell.
Und deswegen ist es sehr schwierig vorherzusehen, wann sozusagen alles so morsch
geworden ist, dass es wirklich auseinander bricht.
Aber diese Offensive der Ukraine hat definitiv den Stuhl kräftig angesägt. Sagen wir es mal so.
Da sind noch ein paar Beine und so schnell wird es dann sicherlich nicht gehen.
Aber diese Maßnahme hatte jetzt eigentlich aus Putins Perspektive alles,
was er eigentlich nicht haben wollte.
Also Russland an sich wird angegangen. Ja, dieses ganze Zweifeln an der Zar
kann sicherstellen, dass wir alle sicher sind. Kann er nämlich nicht offensichtlich.
Ja, er schafft es halt, das Blame Game nach wie vor so zu verteilen,
aber das wird halt irgendwann auch enden.
Also irgendwann sind einfach nicht mehr genug Leute zum Feuern da.
Dazu bringt eben diese neue Offensive der Ukrainer auch so dieses Gefühl mit,
wenn sie sich heute Kurs geschnappen können.
Was garantiert uns eigentlich, dass wenn wir alle unsere Truppen jetzt dahin
verlagert haben und anfangen, die da so raus zu bekämpfen,
kann es nicht sein, dass sie dann irgendwie schwupps alle wieder raus sind und
drei Stunden später stehen die 300 Kilometer weiter links und machen da Ärger
und dann geht der ganze Spaß wieder von vorne los und wenn wir uns darauf eingestellt
haben, dann greifen sie in der Krim an.
Und diese zunehmende Verbesserung, also obwohl es immer noch schlecht ist,
aber sagen wir mal jetzt mit diesen F-16s zum Beispiel, die wir letztes Mal
schon ausführlich diskutiert haben, ist ja jetzt wirklich ein Punkt erreicht,
wo eine spürbare militärische Verbesserung auch stattfindet.
Und irgendwann wird dann halt bei allem Widerstand der Punkt auch erreicht sein,
wo die Russen einfach kulminieren, wo sie einfach nicht mehr in der Lage sind,
noch eine Schippe draufzulegen.
Und die Tatsache, dass jetzt schon so viel über Friedensgespräche aus russischer
und vor allem aus belarussischer Seite geredet wird, ist schon mal so ein erstes Indiz,
dass ihnen eigentlich schon langsam die Sache zu heiß wird.
Aber sie können jetzt natürlich ohne Gesichtsverlust da nicht so richtig raus.
Also es kann schon sein, dass wir schon den Anfang sehen, dass die Russen panisch
werden und in irgendeiner Form versuchen aus dieser Nummer nochmal rauszukommen,
was halt sehr schwierig ist.
Ja, weil üblicherweise, also so ein Krieg endet natürlich oder damals im Zweiten
Weltkrieg war es dann tatsächlich so, da musste man dann so weit gehen,
dass man sagen komplett die Verteidigungsfähigkeit von Deutschland oder die
Kampffähigkeit letztlich komplett beseitigt hat.
Also dass man sozusagen komplett gesiegt hat.
Normalerweise gehen Kriege oder Konflikte aber nicht so lange,
sondern was halt normalerweise passiert ist,
dass halt plötzlich die Kosten oder die Schmerzen in einem relativ kurzen Zeitraum
zu groß werden, dass man sie noch ertragen kann.
Wenn es halt so Stück für Stück geht, so scheibchenweise, dann passt man sich an, dann hat man Zeit.
Also wenn jetzt beispielsweise, was jetzt noch fehlen würde,
vielleicht wäre das jetzt entweder...
In Georgien es zu einem Regierungswechsel kommt und plötzlich die Georgier sich
überlegen, dass sie die Russen nicht mehr im Land haben wollen.
Oder, ja, die Tschetschenen vielleicht,
dass es dort einen Seitenwechsel gibt, auf einmal entweder mit oder ohne Kadyrov.
Kadyrov, so weiß man auch nicht, aber bei Kadyrov, dem würde ich auch immer
zutrauen, zu sagen, okay, jetzt Putin, also wenn ich mich jetzt nicht absetze
von Putin, dann bin ich auch dran.
Und solche Ereignisse, wenn die zusätzlich noch kommen, plus militärische Erfolge,
das könnte dann tatsächlich dazu führen, dass dann Putin das nicht durchhält.
Aber solange das nur scheibchenweise geht und langsam vorangeht,
gut, das hier ist jetzt nicht gerade scheibchenweise, aber ein anderes Ding ist,
dass ja unklar ist und eher unwahrscheinlich, dass die Ukraine sowas noch an
ein, zwei oder drei anderen Stellen auch machen kann im Moment.
Weil Ukraine hat schon tatsächlich Reserven und aber auch tatsächlich Truppen
von der Front abgezogen für diese Invasion,
die sie dort vorgenommen haben.
Also es müsste jetzt, müssten jetzt noch mehr Scheite ins Feuer,
so damit da was passiert aus meiner Sicht und sind noch nicht am Ende der Fahnenstange
oder Ende des Krieges angekommen.
Leider nicht.
Gut, ich denke damit können wir die politische und militärische Betrachtung
dieser Invasion erstmal so abschließen.
Zum Schluss sollten wir vielleicht nochmal auf zwei Sachen eingehen.
Letztes Mal haben wir ja schon ausführlich über das Potenzial,
die diese F-16-Kampfflugzeuge der Ukraine so stellen können,
schon gemutmaßt und mal einen Ausblick über die Technik gegeben.
Das wollen wir jetzt nicht alles nochmal wiederholen. Aber in der Zwischenzeit,
also innerhalb der letzten Wochen, sind nun die ersten paar Flugzeuge auch tatsächlich
in der Ukraine angekommen.
Das ist auch bestätigt. Die sind schon in der Luft gesehen worden,
beziehungsweise wurde das Ganze auch mit einem verhältnismäßig großen Bremborium
von der ukrainischen Regierung ja auch präsentiert.
Und ja, man geht jetzt davon aus, dass diese vielleicht zehn Flugzeuge teilweise
eben schon für Einsätze zum Einsatz gebracht werden könnten und wahrscheinlich
auch für Training und Reparaturschulung on the ground.
Das wissen wir alles nicht, ob die jetzt nicht vielleicht doch teilweise im
Westen gewartet werden etc. Aber es ist einiges darüber bekannt geworden,
wie sie denn jetzt tatsächlich ausgerüstet sind.
Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist die Ausrüstung dieser Maschinen dann doch
noch ein bisschen besser, als man vielleicht hätte vermuten können.
Also die kommen mit der neuesten Steuersoftware daher und mit guten Radaren
und können ein relativ großes Arsenal an Waffen zum Einsatz bringen, oder?
Ja.
Ja, das Problem ist natürlich,
aber eine ganze Menge Probleme damit verbunden, die alle auch erwartet worden
sind und mit denen die Ukraine jetzt umgehen muss.
Erstens das ganze Wartungsthema sowieso, dann aber das Problem,
dass die halt relativ saubere Pisten brauchen und die Russen natürlich nichts
lieber tun würden, als die F-16s zu zerstören.
Das heißt, die Ukrainer sind da auch sehr vorsichtig in dem,
was und wo sie dort machen.
Und ja, das andere Problem ist natürlich so,
diese Kampfflugzeuge haben natürlich auch keine riesen Reichweite,
Aber es ist deutlich besser als jetzt bei vielen der sowjetischen Modelle, die sie fliegen.
Also immerhin kann so eine F-16 halt 860 Kilometer weit fliegen in der Luft-Boden-Rolle.
Parry-Range ist halt 4200 Kilometern mit Zusatztanks, aber dann hast du halt keine Waffen dabei.
Also irgendwo zwischen 860 und 4200 Kilometern beträgt die Reichweite und dann
will man natürlich auch noch wieder zurückkommen und es hängt dann auch stark
von der Höhe ab, in der man unterwegs ist.
Also ich will sagen, es ist halt nicht so ganz einfach und mit der relativ geringen
Zahl, die sie jetzt auch haben,
können sie natürlich jetzt keinen massiven Angriff fliegen oder so.
Plus, was wahrscheinlich das größte Problem ist, ist, dass jetzt die ukrainischen
Piloten jetzt auch erstmal lernen müssen.
Und man geht davon aus, dass sie im Moment der Schwerpunkt darauf liegt,
tatsächlich in der Praxis auszuprobieren, vorsichtig so, was können wir denn
machen und einfach zu lernen, tatsächlich mit den Dingern umzugehen.
Und sie ansonsten vor allem die Piloten und auch die Flugzeuge nicht allzu sehr zu gefährden. Aber.
Ich denke mal, an irgendeinem Punkt wird es spürbar werden, aber im Moment ist
sie nicht wirklich sichtbar.
Also im Moment kann man, also sichtbar, ja, sie fliegen, aber es gab jetzt noch keine Meldung darüber,
dass sie in irgendwelche Kämpfe verwickelt waren oder in irgendeiner Weise an
der Front zum Einsatz gekommen.
Sind. Aber früher oder später wird das natürlich passieren.
Und so, ich rechne eher damit, dass sie.
Wahrscheinlich die Dinger nutzen werden, in erster Linie um weiter die gegnerische
Luftverteidigung mit Harms zu bekämpfen.
So, dass sie halt gucken, weil das konnten sie zwar bisher auch,
aber nur sehr eingeschränkt mit vorprogrammierten Waffen.
Was sie jetzt Wozu sie jetzt in der Lage sind, ist, dass das Flugzeug selbst
erkennt, oh, da wurde jetzt ein Radar eingeschaltet,
dann die entsprechenden Daten von diesem Radar an die Rakete übermittelt und
dann eben dynamisch Luftabwehr bekämpft werden kann.
Weil oft ist es so, dass viele der Stellungen auch einfach aus sind,
um eben nicht geortet werden zu können.
Und dass die oft nur erst dann eingeschaltet werden, wenn ein anderes Radar sagt, da ist irgendwas.
Und man die dann oft auch gerne verlegt, nachdem man die einmal benutzt hat.
Und da funktionierte dann die bisherigen Angriffe nicht so gut.
Und die andere Sache ist natürlich, dass man sich vorstellen kann,
dass sie dann mit den Langstrecken-Luft-Luft-Raketen vielleicht auch das eine
oder andere feindliche Flugzeug dann bekämpfen.
Aber davon hat man bisher noch nichts gehört.
Und ich denke vor allem werden sie jetzt erstmal zur Raketenabwehr auch mitverwendet werden.
Also wenn jetzt große Bomber starten, weiß die Ukraine ja schon Stunden vorher,
okay da kommt jetzt vielleicht was an und dann große Raketen wie diese Iskandar,
die ja auch großes Zerstörungspotenzial haben und bisher nicht immer abgefangen werden konnten,
da helfen ja die F-16 auch, weil die können dann schnell aufsteigen und die
können dann halt solche Raketen auch tracken und auch zerstören.
Also das sind alles so Aspekte. Also ich denke man sollte noch nicht so viel
erwarten jetzt so, aber sie sind da und ab jetzt kann sich die Situation dahingehend
halt dann doch schnell verbessern.
Denke ich, denke ich auch.
Ein paar andere interessante Beobachtungen. Ich hatte es vorhin schon erwähnt.
Es wird jetzt in zunehmendem Maße so ein Roboter- und Drohnenkrieg,
der jetzt hier parallel noch mitkommt.
Über Drohnen haben wir ja schon gesprochen und die hohe Produktionszahl.
Vor allem ist die Vielfalt an Drohnen, die mittlerweile von der Ukraine eingesetzt
werden, wirklich bemerkenswert.
Ich hatte es auch schon mal eingangs erwähnt. Es gibt ja dieses Video,
wo eine Drohne, Eine ukrainische Drohne in Kursk, ein Kampfhubschrauber,
der Russen verfolgt und dann, wie man das bisher nur mit Fahrzeugen auf dem Boden gesehen hat,
so weit verfolgt hat und dann in der Nähe explodiert ist, sodass wahrscheinlich
der Heckrotor zerstört wurde.
Dieser Abschuss wurde auch von den Russen bestätigt.
Also das weiß man, das hat wirklich auch so stattgefunden.
Das ist natürlich eine weitere Bedrohung für die Hubschrauber-Armada der Russen,
die ja durchaus ein Asset in ihrem Park ist.
Ich hatte mich nämlich gefragt, also wir kennen ja normalerweise in der Regel
so die normalen Quadcopter, die ja eher so flach sind. Aber es gibt so ein paar Amateure, die...
Halt schnell fliegende Quadcopter gebaut haben, die dann im Prinzip ein bisschen
wie eine Rakete geshaped sind.
Und die Dinger erreichen tatsächlich bis zu 300 kmh Geschwindigkeit.
Weil ich mich nämlich gefragt hatte, oder vielleicht gefragt,
okay, wie kann jetzt so eine kleine Drohne, Wir kennen, die fliegen vielleicht 50, 60 kmh.
Einen Hubschrauber, der 100, 150, 200 fliegt, eigentlich erwischen kann.
Und meine Vermutung ist, dass sie auch diese YouTube-Videos gelesen haben von
diesen 300 kmh Drohnen und irgendwas genau in der Richtung gebaut haben,
die dann auch in der Lage sind, schneller als ein Hubschrauber zu fliegen.
Zumindest für ein paar Minuten. Also ich weiß nicht.
Ob diese Hubschrauber jetzt immer so schnell unterwegs sind.
Also diese Hubschrauber müssen ja nicht unbedingt so schnell fliegen.
Das sind ja jetzt keine Kampfflugzeuge, sondern die können ja auch langsam sein.
Und diese spezielle Videosequenz, die da veröffentlicht wurde,
macht auf mich nicht so den Eindruck, als ob der mit 120 Stundenkilometern unterwegs war.
Der war eher so gemütlich am Start.
Ja, das täuscht.
Aber wir wissen, Drohnen können diese Geschwindigkeit erreichen und sie können
mittlerweile auch Formel-1-Fahrzeuge als Kamera begleiten.
Das funktioniert alles, kann durchaus sein, dass das hier auch ein Teilaspekt
ist. Der andere Aspekt ist, dass man eben auch genug Sprengladung dabei hat,
um so ein Heckrotor zu zerstören. Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich auch weniger das Problem.
Aber halt das Tracking ist unter Umständen halt dahingehend optimiert worden.
Auf jeden Fall kommt diese Bedrohung noch mit dazu.
Dann habe ich gesehen, Bodenversorgungsfahrzeuge, die autonom unterwegs sind.
Also das sind jetzt im Prinzip einfach so fahrende Fahrzeuge.
Tischchen, die quasi Sachen transportieren zur Truppenversorgung.
Das gibt es auch schon so ein bisschen länger, aber wird wohl auch immer ausgefeilter.
Also wir hatten das glaube ich in Avtivka schon, dass die von Beobachtungsdrohnen
begleitet und dann entsprechend ferngesteuert werden.
Aber jetzt ist eben auch schon von selbstfahrenden Fahrzeugen die Rede,
denen also gesagt wird, so hier, bringen das da mal hin und die sich dann irgendwie
selber ihren Weg bahnen.
Und für die Infanterie kommen jetzt auch solche Roboterhunde zum Einsatz.
Den man ja auch schon mal öfter gesehen hat.
Das ist ja mittlerweile ein bewährtes Bewegungsmodell für Roboter,
dass sie sich quasi wie so ein Hund bewegen.
Und die werden dann in engen Kampfsituationen zum Einsatz gebracht,
einfach als Aufklärungsgeräte.
Ja, da habe ich auch gesehen, die Frage ist dann natürlich immer,
sind das jetzt sozusagen eine Handvoll Prototypen oder können die auch in nennenswerten
Stückzahlen produziert werden,
um wirklich einen Impact zu haben?
Also gerade bei den Roboterhunden habe ich mich das gefragt.
Aber ja, man wird es sehen. Ich meine, wenn die Dinger sich als nützlich und
erfolgreich erweisen, kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass die Krainer dann relativ
schnell auch eine Serienproduktion auf dem Boden stampfen.
Aber die Geräte, die ich oder das, was ich da jetzt gesehen habe,
bei denen also diese Roboterhunde speziell, habe ich jetzt zwei Stück von gesehen.
Während du von jetzt den normalen Quadcoptern sie gelegentlich schon mal komplette
Parkplätze vollgestellt abfilmen, wenn eine neue Lieferung gekommen ist, wo man weiß,
dass es sich um Tausende am Tag handelt, die da geliefert werden.
Ja, aber so fing es an. Also am Anfang waren auch die FPV-Drohnen ein Unikum
im Kampf um Kiew, ganz zu Beginn des Krieges.
Da kamen nämlich dann sozusagen die Leute, das war ja noch gar nicht Teil der
Armee damals, sondern das waren ja irgendwelche Privatleute,
die auch sonst viel mit Koptern gemacht haben. Die haben gesagt,
hier, lass mich da mal rumfliegen, ich gucke mal, wo die Russen sind.
Und wie schnell ging es dann mit automatischem Abwurf von Granaten etc.
Bis hin zu den Kamikaze-Drohnen.
Die waren dann selber mobil mit Quads unterwegs, also mit diesen vierrädrigen
Motorrädern im Prinzip.
Und ja, da kann ich mich noch gut dran erinnern.
Gut, dann hatten wir noch eine Frage, eine Anregung, ein Feedback aus den Kommentaren.
Schon ein paar Sendungen her, ich hätte mir das hier mal notiert,
vielleicht gehen wir da auch noch mal kurz drauf ein.
Ich habe jetzt die Originalformulierung nicht mehr notiert, aber im Kern ging
die Frage in Richtung Verwendung von Cluster-Munition in diesem Krieg,
die ja von beiden Seiten eingesetzt wird, von den Russen von Anfang an,
von den Ukrainern seit die Amerikaner diese geliefert haben.
Anderthalb Jahr her, glaube ich, dass das begonnen hat und das ist ja mittlerweile sehr verbreitet.
Man sieht das bei sehr vielen Angriffen.
Was meinen wir mit Cluster-Munition? Wir meinen Munition, die halt jetzt nicht
einen Bomben-Impact an einer Stelle hat, sondern im Prinzip eine Munition,
die eine Vielfalt von Bomblets aussetzt,
die dann nochmal alle für sich separat explodieren.
Eine andere Variante sind natürlich Bomben wie diese Attack-Gims,
die dann tausende von kleinen Tungstenkügelchen haben und die dann einfach einen
entsprechenden mechanischen Impact haben.
Sprich man vergrößert das eigentliche Angriffsziel. Klasse.
Munitionen, die jetzt der ersten Bauart, die also quasi nochmal so mit mehreren
kleinen Bomblets arbeiten, sind ja unter anderem mal geächtet worden von verschiedenen
Ländern, darunter auch Deutschland.
Ja, aber...
Weil sie halt so ein Problem sind bei der Minen, beim Minenauf... Also beim...
Ja, also... Ja, Russland und die USA sind dem nie beigetreten.
Letztlich, ich meine, die andere Sache ist ja die ganze Landminendebatte.
Also Landminen gehören im Prinzip in dieselbe Kategorie oder schaffen halt dieselben Probleme.
Ja, nichtsdestotrotz verwenden beide Seiten Landminen in größerer Größe.
Zahl und wird wahrscheinlich in 100 Jahren noch in der Ukraine es damit zu tun
haben, um manche Gegenden dann zu entminen.
Also das ist halt nun mal ein Problem. Und generell, ja,
ich sag mal, wirklich human ist keine Art von Kriegswaffe.
Aber es gibt natürlich unterschiedliche Abstufungen.
Und die Russen scheinen jetzt auch vermehrt chemische Waffen einzusetzen wieder.
Die da plus so, was ich halt auch gruselig finde,
hatten wir halt auch die Air-Fuel-Bombs,
die dann gewaltige Explosionswirkung haben und dann ja Leute,
die da zu nah dran sind, einfach durch die Druckwelle es in die Lunge zerreißt und so.
Also es ist alles nicht schön.
Es ist alles nicht schön, wobei ich in der Abstufung, wie gesagt,
Clusterbomben und Minen sind irgendwo in der Mitte.
Aber es gibt dann noch andere Waffen, die dann in größerem Maße geächtet sind.
Bis hin zu, wie sagt man jetzt, auch Blendwaffen oder generell Waffen,
die halt unnötig viel Leid verursachen, wozu dann eben auch chemische Waffen gehören.
Aber chemische Waffen taugen nicht so viel, wie viele Leute glauben.
Sie kommen deswegen nicht so häufig zum Einsatz, weil sie einfach nicht so besonders tauglich sind.
Während jetzt diese Cluster-Munition...
Eignet sich in erster Linie wunderbar zur Bekämpfung jetzt von Flughäfen.
Zum Beispiel so, wo viele Flugzeuge stehen oder für Truppen an Sammlungen.
Und einfach ganz pragmatisch, die USA verwendet die nicht mehr.
Hat aber noch jede Menge davon, deren Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum langsam abläuft.
Und ja, es ist halt dann einfach auch billiger für die USA, die in die Ukraine
zu schicken, als sie dann selber aufwendig zu entsorgen, weil die sind halt gefährlich.
Die müssen halt dann ja aufgebohrt und aufgesägt werden unter speziellen Bedingungen.
Und die Ukraine kann sie gerade aus verschiedenen Gründen gut gebrauchen,
unter anderem deswegen, weil sie nicht die Luftfreiheit hat.
Also deswegen benutzen die Amerikaner die nicht mehr, weil sie einfach Waffen
haben, die sie auch ans Ziel bringen können, die dann mit größerer Präzision Ziele bekämpfen.
Und generell kann man auch glaube ich sagen.
Dass je präziser eine Waffe, umso weniger Gefahr besteht,
dass Zivilisten zu Schaden kommen oder dass man unnötig viel zerstört.
Was auch so ein Problem war, gesehen haben, dass Russland halt,
Russlands Mangel an Präzisionswaffen am Ende dazu geführt hat,
dass sie komplette Städte in Schutt und Asche legen mussten,
weil sie eben einfach nicht präzise genug treffen können.
Und das aber auch in Kauf nehmen, also es klemmt sie jetzt nicht groß.
Genau. Und ich sag mal, ob
du jetzt eine Cluster-Rakete abschießt oder ob sie dann eine Salve aus fünf
Mehrfachraketenwerfern mit jeweils 20 Sprengköpfen,
die dann irgendwo auch landen, wo auch immer sie gerade hinfliegen,
so in einem Umkreis von 100, 200 Metern oder so.
Also das ist so die Genauigkeit von diesen ja, grad.
MLRS so, dass man,
Grundsätzlich sagen kann, am liebsten natürlich Präzisionswaffen, aber
in der aktuellen Situation in der Ukraine sind in bestimmten Einsatzzenarien
einfach diese Clusterbomben vorzuziehen und machen jetzt auch keinen großen
Unterschied bei der Zahl der Minen, die da ausgebracht wurde.
Und was ja auch viel gemacht wird,
also die Amerikaner liefern jetzt auch gerade aktuell neue Munition für Artilleriegranaten,
die zum Fernverminen dient,
also wo du dann fünf Panzerminen drin hast und wo du dann auf eine Entfernung
von 16 Kilometern per Artillerie Minen ausbringen kannst, Um dann,
was weiß ich, irgendwo dann den Vormarsch zu stoppen, indem du dann vor eine
Kolonne dann die Minen schickst und so.
Und die sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt besser, wenn man von besser überhaupt
reden kann, im Sinne von humaner.
Genau. Und Minenverlegeroboter und so weiter.
Also das Kernproblem vom Krieg ist Krieg und Minen und nicht explodierte Waffen
sind natürlich ein Problem,
aber die werden jetzt gerade in diesem Konflikt durch den Einsatz von diesen
Cluster-Munitionen nicht extrem viel größer, Sondern wir werden nach diesem
Krieg und hin das Problem haben,
dass es sich hierbei um die wohl am dichtesten verminsten Gebiete der Welt handeln
wird und das noch auf Dekaden hin.
Es ist nur zu hoffen, dass eben jetzt diese ganzen autonomen Roboter,
die ja so bedrohlich erscheinen im Kriegsgeschehen,
dass die gerade auch beim Entfernen, Finden und Entfernen von Minen dann auch hilfreich sein können.
Also dass man quasi automatisierte Minenfinder und automatisierte Minenautomaten.
Wie sagt man, Endminer baut, die halt in der Lage sind, diese Minen entweder
detonieren zu lassen oder halt aufgeschraubt bekommen und ausgeschaltet bekommen.
Okay, gut. Letzter Punkt,
das müssen wir jetzt nochmal nachliefern, weil das jetzt gerade in den Medien
nochmal eine Rolle gespielt hat, als es die Anschläge auf die Nord Stream 2
Pipeline gab in der Ostsee,
haben wir auch ja viel darüber fabuliert, was denn nun dahinter stecken könnte.
Du hast dich ja auch sehr intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt,
was da jetzt konkret passiert ist und was beobachtet werden konnte.
Und ja, ein Stück weit haben wir uns natürlich auch ins Spekulationsgewitter,
begeben und überlegt, wer könnte denn jetzt hier einen Grund gehabt haben.
Ich denke, unser Konsens Es war so ein bisschen ja am ehesten noch Russland selber.
Schon seit einigen Monaten gab es ja, wann ist das überhaupt nochmal passiert, wann war das?
Das ist auch schon anderthalb Jahre her. Also seitdem gibt es halt auch in Deutschland
Recherchen, ich glaube vor allem vom Spiegel vorangetrieben,
die tatsächlich eine ukrainische Gruppe vermuteten.
Und das war dann lange Zeit darum still und jetzt gab es wohl den Versuch von
deutschen Behörden in Polen, jemanden, also Ukrainer verhaften zu lassen,
den sie nach wie vor unterstellen,
bei dieser Aktion beteiligt gewesen zu sein.
Was weißt du darüber?
Ja, also es gibt jetzt eben einen
Haftbefehl gegen einen ukrainischen Tauchlehrer, der in Polen gelebt hat,
sich aber wohl jetzt in die Ukraine abgesetzt hat.
Und außerdem gibt es noch einen Verdacht gegen zwei weitere professionelle Taucher,
aber man hat da wohl nicht genug Beweise oder Indizien für einen Haftbefehl bisher.
Die Ukraine weist jegliche Beteiligung zurück, aber es gibt halt Presseberichte,
dass ein ukrainischer Agent namens Roman Schawinski,
der Koordinator der Angriffe gewesen
sein soll und die Logistik des Sabotagekommandos erledigt haben soll.
Und ja, also sein Name wurde jetzt von verschiedenen Geheimdiensten genannt.
Das Interessante oder Merkwürdige daran ist aber, dass Tchewinsky gerade in
der Ukraine in Haft sitzt.
So, weil er,
also es muss ein ziemlich wilder Typ sein oder der hat wohl unter anderem so organisiert,
dass irgendwie ein Separatist namens Semach, der am Abschuss von MH17 beteiligt gewesen sein sollte.
Entführt worden ist aus Russland unter anderem.
Und dann hat wohl Czerwinski irgendwie versucht,
auch in Russland Dutzende Wagner-Söldner zu rekrutieren zum Schein,
um sie dann in die Ukraine zu entführen.
So und angeblich sitzt er aber jetzt in U-Haft,
weil er angeblich bei dem Versuch, einen russischen Kampfpiloten zum Überlaufen
zu bewegen, seine Kompetenzen überschritten haben soll, was auch immer das bedeutet.
Und so, er ist wohl auch nicht gerade als Freund von Selenskyj bekannt.
So. Insofern, also wenn man jetzt mal das für bare Münze nimmt,
was da jetzt in der Presse veröffentlicht wurde und ich würde sagen,
ja, das ist nicht völlig unglaubwürdig oder nicht völlig von der Hand zu weisen.
Ansonsten scheint es nicht so zu sein, dass jetzt das Ganze von Selensky ausgegangen ist.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
dass irgendein durchgeknallter Geheimdienstler, sagen da,
irgendwas angeleiert hat mit auch vielleicht Rückendeckung von Polen.
Die ja auch, gut.
Ob jetzt die USA davon wussten oder nicht, scheinbar nicht möglich,
aber Ukraine selbst bestreitet,
also Zelensky bestreitet, dass die Ukraine in irgendeiner Weise an den Sprengungen beteiligt war.
Aber was halt bei diesen Geheimdienstoperationen und Geheimdienstberichten immer
der Fall ist, ist halt schwierig,
da wirklich hinter die Kulissen zu gucken, weil die natürlich alle massiv auch
mit Desinformationen arbeiten und so.
Aber ich würde jetzt sagen, also aus meiner Sicht steht es jetzt, würde ich sagen, ja,
würde ich dem eine 50-prozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit einräumen,
dass Ukrainer und Polen tatsächlich daran beteiligt waren.
Aber ich halte es für unwahrscheinlich,
dass das Ganze von der Spitze der Regierung ausgegangen ist oder Selenskyj sein Okay dazu gegeben hat.
Wobei es natürlich auch Black Ops gibt, wo,
man einfach nicht will dass bestimmte Leute sagen, davon wissen,
damit sie es halt hinterher abstreiten können und ich sag mal.
Also, ja, sieht alles ein bisschen unklar aus und insbesondere,
dass halt jetzt der angebliche Drahtzieher in der Ukraine im Gefängnis sitzt,
ist, muss man sagen, ja, unklar, was das jetzt zu bedeuten hat.
Aber wie gesagt, deutet darauf hin, dass er was damit zu tun haben könnte.
So, auf der anderen Seite, das Problem eben ist, du weißt nie,
wer wen wofür eigentlich bezahlt hat.
Und oft wissen die Leute, die Anschläge begehen, noch nicht mal,
für wen sie denn eigentlich gerade genau arbeiten.
Speziell, wenn es sich um irgendwelche Trupps von Tauchlehrern handelt,
die dann mit einer Segeljacht unterwegs sind.
Das kann auch, hatten wir damals auch spekuliert, kann auch einfach irgendein
ukrainischer Oligarch gewesen sein, der sich überlegt hat.
Hier, ich will mal was für mein Land tun.
Oder ja, also ich fürchte, wir werden noch ein bisschen länger warten müssen
und vielleicht nie vollständig Klarheit darüber erlangen.
Aber definitiv verdichten sich jetzt die Anzeichen für eine ukrainisch-polnische Beteiligung.
Ich habe ja immer noch so ein bisschen Zweifel, Weil wir hatten ja auch ursprünglich
mal so den Aufwand, der da getrieben werden muss, in diesen Tiefen wirklich
diese Springsätze anzubringen, das durchzuführen, das logistisch auf die Kette
zu bekommen finanziell.
Vieles wies für mich ja schon darauf hin, dass es schon eher staatsgebundene
Ressourcen benötigt, um dort wirklich aktiv zu werden.
Dass da jetzt einfach irgendwelche Leute im Segelboot rausfahren und irgendwie
solche hochgradig kompliziert aufgesetzten und ja auch gut geschützten Pipelines gespürt bekommen.
Vielleicht unterschätzen wir auch nur, was so ukrainische Tauchlehrer irgendwie
alles in der Lage sind zu tun.
Oder wie gut diese Pipeline gebaut wurde. Also we don't know.
Ja, we don't know. Aber ich sag mal, ja, gibt jetzt Anzeichen,
die eben auf Ukraine und Polen hindeuten.
Aber interessant an der Sache ist auch, dass jetzt mittlerweile auch Position
klar gemacht wurde, auch von Deutschland.
Scheint, naja gut, nur weil irgendwelche Ukrainer jetzt da eine Pipeline sprengen,
Werden wir das jetzt nicht der gesamten Ukraine ankreiden oder unsere Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine plötzlich einstellen,
nur weil da irgendwie so eine Pipeline vor zwei Jahren gesprengt wurde und das
ist eh alles Schnee von gestern.
Und am Ende hat es ja auch ihr Gutes so, es hat dann ein bisschen die Erpressbarkeit
Deutschlands beendet, was so russisches Gas angeht.
Und die Lichter sind hier nicht ausgegangen, aber es war natürlich teuer,
die ganze Aktion. Aber auf der anderen Seite floss ja eh auch gerade kein Gas durch die Pipeline.
Und insofern kann man den Ukrainern fast auch nur dankbar sein.
Wenn sie es waren. Ja, wenn sie es waren.
Aber dieselben Leute natürlich, die das dann kritisieren, sind dann wahrscheinlich auch die,
ja, kritisieren eigentlich auch Öl-Großkonzerne oder in dem Fall gar Energie-Großkonzerne,
die dann einen dicken Reibach machen.
Und insofern, ja, also ich persönlich würde es der Ukraine jetzt nicht allzu übel nehmen,
wenn sich rausstellt dass sie da wirklich beteiligt waren sondern eigentlich,
man kann fast sagen hat es Deutschland ein Stück weit verdient so, weil ja.
Nord Stream auch ein Objekt definitiv gewesen ist,
was die ukrainische Souveränität untergraben hat und dessen Existenz möglicherweise
auch Putin ermutigt hat,
überhaupt diesen Einmarsch zu tun.
Alles natürlich wilde Spekulationen, aber ja, ich denke mal einfach,
das wird jetzt weiter keine großen Auswirkungen haben, weil das Thema ist auch
so ein bisschen durch oder von der Entwicklung eigentlich überholt worden.
Und, ja, würde ich sagen, kräht kein Hahn mehr nach, aber,
so ist zumindest die offizielle Reaktion, sieht halt so aus,
dass sagt, na, so be it. Whatever.
Gut, Pavel, dann würde ich sagen, beenden wir mal diese Sendung an dieser Stelle auf.
Ich denke, jetzt haben wir irgendwie unseren Senf ausreichend abgegeben zu der Situation.
Und wir Wir hoffen natürlich, dass euch das weitergeholfen hat,
dass das zur Einordnung beiträgt.
Wir beobachten weiterhin diesen Konflikt und wir tun es auch weiterhin mehr oder weniger täglich.
Es ist irgendwie schon so zu einem Automatismus geworden.
Mich fragen immer viele Leute, wie ich das irgendwie alles ertragen kann.
Und sie müssten sich da ja ausblenden aus dem ganzen Geschehen,
um das irgendwie für sich noch einsortiert zu bekommen.
Und ich kann das Gefühl sehr gut nachvollziehen, allerdings ist es bei mir genau andersrum.
Braucht das fast, diese permanente Beschäftigung damit, weil,
ja, weniger wegen des Doom, sondern es ist natürlich insgesamt eine bedrohliche Situation.
Sie wird jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr von allen so als so bedrohlich wahrgenommen
und in Deutschland ist es ja nun ohnehin so, dass wir ganz gut entfernt davon sind.
Aber vergesst nicht, dieser Konflikt ist nah genug.
Man fährt da nicht so lang hin. Und am Ende ist es auch unser Krieg,
weil es gegen Europa geht.
Wenn Russland nicht in der Ukraine gestoppt wird, dann wird er halt erst später gestoppt werden.
Und dann kommt der Konflikt nochmal sehr viel näher und wird noch sehr viel
mehr Leid und Unsicherheit auslösen.
Und auch wenn hohe Kosten damit verbunden sind, diese Unterstützung zu leisten,
Es ist ein Witz im Vergleich zu dem, was wir leisten müssten,
wenn wir diesen Krieg selber führen würden.
Auch wenn ich persönlich der Meinung bin,
dass wir unser Engagement noch deutlich steigern müssten,
um einfach das Problem schneller loszuwerden und all diese ganze gefürchtete
Eskalation nicht auch wirklich wahr werden zu lassen.
Wir sehen ja, umso weniger hier unterstützt wird,
umso mehr eskaliert das Ganze dann in gewisser Hinsicht und obliegt nicht mehr
unserer Kontrolle und auch wenn ich finde, dass die Ukraine da nach wie vor
sehr klug vorgeht im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten,
kann es eigentlich nur in unserem Interesse sein, diesen Krieg zu Ende zu bringen
und das können wir leider nur, indem Russland militärisch verdrängt wird.
Es gibt da keine andere Option, weil sich Russland auf nichts anderes einlässt.
Und ja, dementsprechend müssen wir leider diese Krise noch weiter begleiten,
aber wir werden das auf jeden Fall auch weiterhin tun.
So und diesmal enden wir ohne Doomsday, weil die Dinge entwickeln sich jetzt
mal ganz gut, sowohl im Osten als auch im Westen und wir hoffen natürlich, das bleibt auch so.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall waren diese Sendungen irgendwie positiver.
Also die Geschehnisse der letzten zwei Wochen waren insgesamt erst mal erfreulich,
aber man will halt den Tag nicht vor dem Abend loben oder wie ist das denn, jinx it so,
indem man aber ja auf jeden Fall seit langem erfreuliche Nachrichten,
wieder aus der Ukraine oder mehr erfreuliche und auch aus den USA,
wo auch Hoffnung besteht,
dass vielleicht langsam mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Vernunft und Normalität in der Welt einkehrt.
Aber ja, wir werden sehen und ich genieße es im Moment einfach,
diese Nachrichten zu hören, sowohl aus der Ukraine als auch aus den USA und
erfreue mich ein wenig daran.
Gut, insofern vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung dieses
Podcasts und der Meta-Ebene.
Nur das ermöglicht diese kontinuierliche Berichterstattung.
Ich hoffe, ihr tut das auch weiterhin.
Erweckt doch eine regelmäßige Unterstützung der Meta-Ebene unter meta-ebene.me.
Und damit entlassen wir euch hier und sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut.